GOOD MORNING.
THIS WILL BEGIN TODAY'S SOMEONE
HEARING ON MAY SIXTEENTH WE WILL
BEGIN WITH ISSUE ONE
BUT WHEN YOU'RE READY.
.
GO AHEAD OR I CAN IT'S UP TO
YOU.
I GOOD MORNING STARBUCKS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
REVIEWING OUR BCP PROPOSAL FOR
TODAY THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING A HUNDRED FORTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN STATE
GENERAL FUND TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS INTO AND
TOTAL FUNDS FOR TO LIMITED TERM
TO YOUR POSITIONS.
THESE POSITIONS WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PLANNING THE
AGENCY MODEL. THE H. YES
ACTIVITIES WILL INCLUDE
PERFORMING AN IMPACT ANALYSIS OF
POLICY REQUIREMENTS PERTAINING
TO THE AGENCY MODEL.
COORDINATING WITH INTERNAL
PARTNERS TO EVALUATE ALTERNATIVE
SOLUTIONS PARTICIPATING IN
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS SEEDS
COMMUNICATING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND PARTICIPATING IN
THE PROCUREMENT SYSTEM
ESTABLISHMENT. WHICH INCLUDE
SYSTEM DESIGN AND TESTING.
I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE BEGINNING
WITH THIS PROPOSAL BUT AT SOME
POINT WE'RE GONNA WANNA HEAR
ABOUT THE EVP IS.
UNDERTONE OF COURSE ON THIS MAY
BE THE. RIGHT TIME TO OPEN UP
DISCUSSION OF POSSIBLE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND STAFF OF PEACH I
THINK.
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
JUST A BROAD BACKGROUND WE
APPRECIATE THE THOROUGH
DESCRIPTION AND THE AGENDA OF
WHAT ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION IS. IT STANDS OUT
OF A FEDERAL STATUTE ENACTED IN
A DECEMBER OF TWENTY SIXTEEN.
ARE IN A BASICALLY REQUIRES
ELECTRONIC VISIT VERIFICATION.
A OF THE THE THINGS DESCRIBED
ON THE BOTTOM OF PAGE ONE AND ON
TO PAGE TWO OF FOUR PROVIDERS
SERVING.
RECIPIENTS OF ABOUT PERSONAL
CARE SERVICES AND EVENTUALLY
HOME CARE SERVICES AS WELL THE
FEDERAL IMPLEMENTATION DUE DATE.
IS JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY
NINETEEN THERE ARE SOME
EXCEPTIONS ARE THAT ALLOW A
BASED ON GOOD FAITH EFFORTS ARE
UNFORESEEN DIFFICULTIES.
BEFORE.
STATES TO ASK FOR EXCEPT ANNA
EXTENSION OF THAT DATE FOR UP TO
A YEAR A WE'VE ALREADY INDICATED
IN OUR STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THAT
WE PLAN TO DO THAT.
LET ME KNOW IF YOU NEED A
BACKGROUND ON WHAT EVEY V. S.
ARE NOT GOOD OKAY NOW SO PROCESS
WAS THE FEDERAL STATUTE ALSO
REQUIRES A VERY ROBUST
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT PROCESS.
WHICH WE TYPICALLY DO ANYWAY IN
THESE PROGRAMS BUT IT ALSO
REQUIRES THAT THE ULTIMATE
SOLUTION THAT.
SELECTED FOR IMPLEMENTATION. IS
THE LEAST BURDENSOME FOR THE OF
PROVIDERS OF THE SERVICE AND THE
CONSUMERS OF THE SERVICE THAT
VALIDATE THEIR HOURS.
.
YESTERDAY BEFORE THE SENATE I
TOLD YOU WE DIDN'T HAVE CMS
GUIDANCE OF SOMEBODY TOLD ME
THEY WERE LISTENING BECAUSE IT
WAS ISSUED THIS MORNING. WE HAVE
OBVIOUSLY NOT READ IT AT THIS
POINT ABOUT WILL BE LOOKING TO
THAT. AT FIRST GLANCE IT LOOKS
MORE LIKE A CLARIFICATION OF
WHAT THE LAW ACTUALLY SAYS AS
OPPOSED TO THE ACTUAL
IMPLEMENTATION GUIDANCE.
BUT WE RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
COME BACK AND GIVE YOU MORE MORE
DETAILS.
AT SOME POINT IN THE FUTURE.
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES IS CHAU SARAH DESCRIBED
OF FOR YOU THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES PROPOSAL
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS
ACROSS OF THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY THAT PROVIDE
EITHER PERSONAL CARE SERVICES.
OR A HOME HOME.
HOME CARE SERVICES.
AND SO THE SOLUTIONS IN THOSE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS WILL BE
DIFFERENT BASED ON WHERE THEY'RE
STARTING FROM.
SO SPEAKING JUST FOR THE AYE
EXERCISE PROGRAM WE ALSO HAVE A
PROPOSAL TO TO FIND A COUPLE
POSITIONS TO HELP US WITH THE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT PROCESS.
DID SUBMIT THE DOCUMENTATION
THAT WE NEED A TO MAKE CHANGES.
TO THE SCENE UP SYSTEM OF FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF VVV. UP WITH
THERE IS NO OTHER MONEY A
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET FOR ACT
IMPLEMENTATION OF VVV HOWEVER. I
WHAT WE ARE PROPOSING A AND IT'S
A CHANGE TO WHAT'S REFLECTED IN
THE AGENDA BECAUSE WE WE DID
THIS LAST.
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON WERE
WITHDRAWING THE TRAILER BILL
PROPOSAL THAT WE HAD THAT WOULD
ALLOW IMPLEMENTATION BY ALL
COUNTY LETTER. A WITHOUT A RULE
MAKING.
I'M WHERE INSTEAD REPLACING IT
WITH YOU.
WITH IT WITH THE PROPOSED
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE THAT WAS
HANDED OUT AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE HEARING. OF BY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
IF I CAN JUST EXPLAIN BECAUSE IT
IS NEW A WHAT'S THERE ALSO
REPLACES THE LANGUAGE WRITTEN IN
YOUR AGENDA. ON.
.
SO THE FIRST THINGS TO KNOW
DESIGN.
DEVELOPMENT AND INSTALLATION.
AND AS WELL AS THE FEDERAL
TERMS IN THE STATUTE ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR NINETY TURN FEDERAL
FUNDING A SHARE SOFA NINETIES.
FEDERAL TEN TEN STATE.
AND WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING IN IN
THE BUDGET.
ONCE WE'VE HAD TIME TO DIGEST
ON THE FEDERAL GUIDANCE AND
COMPLETE OUR STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS WE WOULD BE
COMING BACK.
TO GIVE A NOTIFICATION TO THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE OUT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
OF AND IN A SIX A ONE THROUGH
FOUR ARE ON THE AGENDA YOU SEE
WE WOULD BE REPRESENTING. A MUCH
MORE ROBUST A REQUEST FOR
FUNDING THAN USUAL IT WOULD
INCLUDE A JUSTIFICATION FOR THE.
INCREASED EXPENDITURES
INCLUDING A WRITTEN PLAN
DESCRIBING THE PROPOSED APPROACH
FOR EVEY V. WITHIN THE IHS US
PROGRAM.
A DESCRIPTION OF THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS THAT WE WENT THROUGH ANY
INPUT WE RECEIVED AND
PARTICULARLY ANY INPUT WE
RECEIVE THAT IS NOT REFLECTED IN
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING.
AND THEN A TIME LINE AND THEN
THE STEPS WE WOULD SEE NECESSARY
TO ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT THE
SOLUTION AND A COST ESTIMATE NOT
ONLY FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUT
THE ONGOING.
ON THERE'S A SUBDIVISION BE IN
THIS LANGUAGE AUTHORIZES THE
TRANSFER OF SOME OF THAT FUNDING
TO STATE OPERATIONS BUDGET FROM
THE LOCAL ASSISTANCE BUDGET. TO
COVER ANY STAFFER CONTRACTS THAT
WE MAY NEED A FOR CONSULTING
SERVICES.
AND THEN IN SUBDIVISION SEE IS
SOME LANGUAGE AROUND OUR RULE
MAKING AUTHORITY.
BY LETTER FOR A LIMITED TWO
YEAR PERIOD.
.
ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT'S BEEN
RAISED WITH THE LANGUAGE AND
WE'RE OPEN TO ADD ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING
THAT HAS A BROAD RANGING IMPACT.
THIS LANGUAGE COVERS JUST THE I
JUST US PROGRAM BUT THERE'S
NEARLY A MILLION PEOPLE ARE THAT
WOULD BE POTENTIALLY AFFECTED BY
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
REQUIREMENT.
AND WE THINK THAT IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT ADVANCE NOTICE
BE GIVEN TO THEM OF WHAT EXACTLY
WE'RE TRYING TO DO BASED ON ALL
OF THE FEEDBACK WE RECEIVE FROM
THEM. ON SO WE'RE OPEN TO ANY
TWO WEEKS OF A LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD MAKE THAT CLEAR BUT I
WANTED TO SAY THAT HERE ON THE
RECORD AS WELL. AND AMANDA
STOPPED AND IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
THEM.
NOW WE WILL BUT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ILIO.
LA UNIFIED SMART ELLIS WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE THE
RESOURCES REQUESTED IN THIS
PROPOSAL DO APPEAR REASONABLE
AND WE UNDERSTAND THE
ADMINISTRATION MAY NEED SOME
FLEXIBILITY IN IMPLEMENTING EVP.
รณ WE WERE CONCERNED WITH THE
ORIGINAL PROPOSED BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE IN TRAILER BILL WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT IT WAS OVERLY
BROAD AND LIMITED LIVE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. AND WE'RE
STILL LOOKING AT THE REVISED
LANGUAGE BUT WE DO THINK IT
APPEARS TO MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THANK YOU.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE ISSUE ONE.
ISN'T ALSO SPEAKING FOR THAT
CALIFORNIA JUST US CONSUMERS
ALLIANCE AND MOST OF THE REVISED
LANGUAGE THAT'S BEEN FOR PUT
FORWARD BY THE ADMINISTRATION IS
OKAY WITH US EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY THE STAFFING.
POSITIONS THAT THEY NEED TO DO
ADEQUATE PLANNING AND
INTERACTION WITH STAKEHOLDERS
WERE CONCERNS THOUGH THAT
THEY'RE STILL LANGUAGE THAN THE
BUDGET BILL.
LANGUAGE PROPOSAL THAT'S OVERLY
BROAD THAT WOULD GIVE THEM AS MR
SERVING COULD DESCRIBE RULE
MAKING AUTHORITY TO IMPLEMENT.
EVEY V. THEIR VERY SPECIFIC
THINGS THAT THEY'VE TALKED ABOUT
THAT SOUND A REASSURING TO
STAKEHOLDERS AS THEY'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING UV VIS THAT THERE
WOULD NOT BE A GPS COMPONENT AND
I COULD GO ONE.
THAT WE WOULD BE VERY HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ON
TO BE SPECIFIC ABOUT WHAT THEY
COULD SPEND MONEY ON. BUT A
BROAD AUTHORITY FOR A TWO YEAR
PERIOD GIVES THE NEXT GOVERNOR
THE ABILITY TO DO SOMETHING THAT
THESE GOOD PEOPLE MAY NOT BE
CURRENTLY CONTEMPLATING WE
CERTAINLY SAW GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER. TURN THE PROGRAM
ON ITS HEAD A WHEN HE CAME INTO
OFFICE AND WE DON'T KNOW WHO THE
NEXT GOVERNOR WOULD BE SO TWO
YEARS OPEN AUTHORITIES. NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE COMFORTABLE
WITH.
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE'VE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT THE.
PROPOSED TO A BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE SURE FROM LAST NIGHT
AND I THINK THAT'S GOING IT IS
IN THE DIRECTION THAT WE CAN
CERTAINLY LIVE WITH I CAN SAY.
YOU KNOW THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS BEEN AND CERTAINLY
TRANSPARENT AND WORKED CLOSELY
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT.
AND I THINK IT'S KAREN HAS
MENTIONED THERE'S ALWAYS CONCERN
OF WHAT TIME MAY HAPPEN. IN THE
THE FUTURE.
SO AS FAR AS THE.
THE LANGUAGE UP FRONT ON THE
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY I THINK
WE'RE FINE WITH THAT AND I THINK
THE ELEMENTS IN THAT ARE GOOD.
BUT BUT WE TO SHARE THE CONCERN
ABOUT THE.
TWO YEAR PERIOD TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT.
WITHOUT A REGULATION THROUGH
ALL COUNTY LETTER HOWEVER I
THINK IF SOMETHING IN THIS
LANGUAGE WAS PERHAPS. TIED MORE
DIRECTLY.
IT INTO THE.
THEY A LANGUAGE SHE IN A TO BE
ANOTHER WORDS IF WE KNOW
EVERYTHING THAT.
IS BEING LAID OUT IN THE PLAN.
BEFORE THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
UTILIZE THE AUTHORITY TO DO YOU
EMPLOYMENT BY ALL COUNTY LETTER
I THINK THAT WOULD MAKE US FEEL
MUCH BETTER AND AND WE CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE WHEN
YOU'RE WORKING AGAINST FEDERAL.
TIMELINES TO MOVE QUICKLY AND
PARTICULARLY WHERE THERE ARE
PENALTIES LE.
TO THE STATES WE DON'T WANNA
STAND IN THE WAY OF DOING THAT
SO SO WE WOULDN'T MIGHT SUGGEST
THAT THERE WOULD BE A WAY TO
TWEAK THAT SOME. AND AND MAYBE
TWO YEARS IS A LITTLE LONG AT
THIS POINT BUT.
MAYBE A YEAR'S WORTH OF THIS
AUTHORITY AND AGAIN THAT FOLLOWS
THE THE.
.
THE INFORMATION THAT'S CONTAINED
IN PEAK THANKS THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
CRISTINA BOSS HAMILTON WITH YOU
W. WE REPRESENT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND I JUST AS WORKERS. A
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM KAPPA IN DRC. WE
ARE VERY THANKFUL TO THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THEIR EFFORTS SO
FAR AT TRANSPARENCY.
AND IN FACT WHAT THEY PROPOSE TO
ME IS.
REALLY THE BEST POSSIBLE WAY TO
DO THIS THAT IS LEAST BURDENSOME
BUT WE JUST NEED TO BUILD IN
ACCOUNTABILITY ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF A FUTURE ADMINISTRATION
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FUTURE
HOLDS. SO WE'RE REALLY TALKING
ABOUT INSURING LEGISLATIVE
ACCOUNTABILITY THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS ROBERT HARRIS ON
BEHALF SEIU CALIFORNIA I WOULD
AGAIN ECHO ALL THOSE THINGS BEER
VERY CONCERNED BUT THE TO YOUR.
ABILITY TO DO THIS WITHOUT BEING
TIED TO ACTUAL THINGS THAT WE
KNOW WON'T HAPPEN.
OTHER THAN PROMISES AND AND WE
TRUST THE PEOPLE UP HERE AND
THEY'VE WORKED VERY HARD. TO BE
OPEN BUT WE'RE STILL CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT TO YOUR AUTHORITY TO
TO DO THINGS WITHOUT.
HAVING WILD THAT COULD AFFECT
THE LIVES OF A MILLION PEOPLE
LIKE WE SAID LOOK UP WITHOUT ANY
LEGISLATIVE AND PUT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS AND.
I'D LIKE TO ECHO MANY OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE JUST SAID.
I DO BELIEVE THERE IS A NEED FOR
LEGISLATIVE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TWO YEAR IMPLEMENTATION SEEMS A
BIT LONG. AND WORLD. WANTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE'S VOICES
ARE HEARD.
AS THIS PROCESS GOES FORWARD WE
WILL WORK WITH YOUR TEAM AND
UNDERSTANDS THAT WE HAVE THE
LOOMING FISCAL.
BUDGET PENALTIES AND THE NEED
FOR HAVING TO WORK WITHIN THE
SYSTEM BUT.
HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROGRAM.
AND HOW IT WILL IMPACT.
PATIENTS CONSTITUENTS PEOPLE OF
OUR GREAT STATE AND. JUST WANTS
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR VOICES ARE
CONTINUED TO BE HEARD THROUGH
THIS PROCESS AND.
OF FIND IT UNLIKELY WE WANT TO
ABDICATE OUR AUTHORITY FOR TWO
YEARS TIME WITHOUT.
WANTING TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY SOME.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE ONE
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
ISSUE
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR THE
BOTTOM NANCY BARGE MEN DIRECTOR.
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. WELL
I'M SORRY.
NO GOOD MORNING SORRY AB HE SAID
GOOD AFTERNOON IT. OUT. WANTED
WINE FAST FORWARDING PARA I'M
TRYING TO HELP YOU GET THROUGH
YOUR COMMITTEE TODAY.
DID IT WORK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO WE'LL GO BACK TO GOOD MORNING
SO WE CAN START THE DAY OVER
YET.
I AM HAPPY TO BE HERE.
I'M HERE WITH CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR JOHN TOILETS WHILE.
.
I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO GO THROUGH
THE.
HIGHLIGHTS OF OUR DEPARTMENT
AND THE.
PROPOSED BUDGET.
SO I'LL I'LL BRIEFLY DO THAT
AND.
MISTER DOYLE WILL GO AHEAD AND
ADDRESS A COUPLE OF ADDITIONAL
ISSUES THAT WERE IDENTIFIED IN
THE AGENDA FOR. A THANK YOU.
SO AS THE AGENDA HAS.
CORRECTLY HIGHLIGHTED A NUMBER
OF AREAS I'LL JUST ON BRIEFLY GO
THROUGH THOSE WITH YOU TODAY.
IN THE PROPOSED I MAY REVISE
WERE LOOKING FOR.
PROJECTIONS FOR SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN UPDATED PROJECTED AS
FAR AS A NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE SERVING
FOR THIS NEXT YEAR.
AB WERE ENDING THE YEAR AT
AROUND THREE HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE NINETY SIX THIS
IS.
REFLECTIVE ARE UPDATED
PROJECTION.
I'M LOOKING AT A DECREASE OF TWO
HUNDRED FORTY ONE INDIVIDUALS
FROM THE PROPOSED GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
THE.
MAY REVISE ALSO REFLECTS
UPDATES ON OUR TOTAL FUNDING A
TOTAL FUNDING OF SIX POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS TOTAL FUN.
I'M AND PART OF THAT IS THAT IN
THREE POINT SEVEN BILLION IN
GENERAL FUND. THIS REFLECTS A
DECREASE I'M FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET OF SIXTEEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION IN TOTAL FUND AND FORTY
FOUR MILLION. DECREASE IN
GENERAL FUND NOT JUST BRIEFLY GO
OVER THAT.
INFORMATION SO IN OPERATIONS
FOR REGIONAL CENTERS.
AND IT REFLECTS A DECREASE OF
TWO POINT ONE MILLION IN ON.
TOTAL FUNDING THREE POINT SIX
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND THIS IS
PRIMARILY DRIVEN BASED ON
UPDATED PROJECTIONS OF REGIONAL
CENTER RENT.
IN PURCHASE OF SERVICE THAT
REFLECTS.
A DECREASE FROM GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET OF FOURTEEN POINT SIX
ON MILLION IN TOTAL FUN AND THEN
ALSO A FORTY. POINT THREE
MILLION GENERAL FUND DECREASE.
PRIMARY DRIVERS FOR FOR THAT IS
REFLECTIVE OF UPDATED CASELOAD
PROJECTIONS BUT ALSO WHEN YOU
SEE BE INCREASE OBJECT FOUND.
AS FAR AS THAT THE ADJUSTMENT
FOR THE I GENERAL FUND DECREASE
THAT'S DRIVEN BASED ON
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENTS SO YOU'LL SEE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A TOTAL FUND
AND THEN REFLECTED OF THE
DECREASE IN THE GENERAL FUND.
GOING TO EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT.
AVERAGE ESTIMATED CASELOAD OF
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY
EIGHT INDIVIDUALS THAT WE WOULD
BE SERVING THROUGH THE REGIONAL
CENTER SERVICE.
I'M DELIVERY DIVERT DELIVERY
SYSTEM THAT REFLECTS A DECREASE
OF WHAT WAS PROJECTED.
BY TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX
INDIVIDUALS.
I'M ALSO LOOKING AT THE
PROJECTED FUNDING I'M AT
ESTIMATES AT SIX POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS TOTAL FUND AND
FOUR POINT ONE. ON OF THAT IS IN
GENERAL FUND THIS REFLECTS A NET
INCREASE OF TWENTY ONE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL FUN.
AGAIN THIS IS REFLECTIVE OF THE
UPDATED CASELOAD IN
EXPENDITURES.
FOR REGIONAL CENTERS WERE
REFLECTING ON PURCHASE OF
SERVICE DECREASE OF SIX POINT
ONE AND BILLION. IN TOTAL FUND
AGAIN ON WITH EIGHTEEN POINT SIX
AGAIN UPDATING SOME OF THE
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS.
IN ADDITION TO UPDATING BASED ON
OUR B. H. T. TRANSITION
INDIVIDUALS WHO DO NOT HAVE.
AUTISM DIAGNOSIS THAT WOULD BE
TRANSITIONING TO MEDI CAL. ON
THERE'S FOR COUNTIES THAT WERE
LOOKING AT THAT WOULD BE DELAYED
BY THREE MONTHS AND SO THAT ARE
UPDATED PROJECTIONS IS RELATED
TO.
.
THAT THE COST OF PROJECTIONS.
ALSO REFLECTS THAT FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE MOVING FROM
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS ON THAT WE
WOULD BE INCREASING FOR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. THIRTY EIGHT
ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALS THAT
WOULD BE MOVING TO THE COMMUNITY
AS SUCH FOR REFLECTING A SLIGHT
INCREASE IN COMMUNITY PLACEMENT
PLANNED ON PLACEMENTS AND THAT'S
TWO POINT TWO MILLION DOLLAR.
TOTAL FUN ON PRODUCTION.
ADDITIONALLY IN THAT.
HOME HEALTH RATE SO THIS IS A
EN ON CORRELATION WITH ON THE
CORRESPONDING MEDI CAL RATE
ADJUSTMENT. IN AREAS OF HOME
HEALTH AGENCY LICENSED
VOCATIONAL NURSES AND REGISTERED
NURSES.
AND SO BECAUSE OUR.
REGULATIONS ARE CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT THE MEDI CAL RADIOS ON WE
HAVE THE TIME CORRELATING
INCREASE
FOR THE HOME HEALTH RATE
INCREASED TWENTY NINE POINT FIVE
MILLION. ON TOTAL FUN.
THIS ALSO AND HAS AN UPDATE ON
THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE
WHILE THAT MAY REVISED DOES.
CONTINUE TO INCLUDE THE
PROJECTION OF ON REINSTITUTING
THE UNIFORM HOLIDAYS SCHEDULED
THE UPDATED PROJECTION. IS
RELATED TO.
OUR ESTIMATE WHEN WE DID THE
ESTIMATE ORIGINALLY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE HAD.
INCORRECTLY USE THAT THE BASE
FOR OUR PROJECTIONS OF TWO
THOUSAND NINE SO WHAT WE DID IS
THAT WE TOOK A LOOK AT THE
UPDATED.
INFORMATION BASED ON OUR
CASELOAD AND UTILIZATION IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN SO THE.
PRODUCTION HERE IS JUST RELATED
TO CORRECTING.
THE AREA IN OUR ESTIMATES AND
THAT REFLECTS FOUR POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLAR DECREASE WHICH IS
ULTIMATELY RESULTING IN AN
ESTIMATED SAVINGS.
ON A RELATED TO THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY ON SCHEDULE.
FOR DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS ON
TODAY WE HAVE FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
SIX INDIVIDUALS IN A
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER. OF THE
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY SIX WE HAVE
TWO HUNDRED NINETY THAT ARE A
PART OF THE.
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS THAT ARE
CLOSING. SO ON MAY REVISE THE
PROJECTION FOR SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN IS THAT WE WOULD JUST
BE ADJUSTING THE POPULATION ONLY
BY THREE INDIVIDUALS AND SO
THERE'S A SLIGHT ADJUSTMENT
RELATED TO. FRUIT FOR THAT THAT
SALARY SAVINGS IS PROJECTED TO
UPDATED SALARY PROJECTIONS FOR.
OUR STAFFING ON AND THAT'S
REFLECTED ELEVEN POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR DECREASE FROM
WHAT WE HAD IN GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
FOR FISCAL YEAR FOR BUDGET YEAR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN I'M MORE
PROTECTING ENDING THE YEAR ON
JUNE THIRTIETH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AT THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE INDIVIDUALS REMAINING AT
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS AT
THAT TIME.
AND WE DO HAVE PROJECTED AS FAR
AS THE MAY REVISE FOR UPDATED
AND INCREASE IN.
OPERATIONS NINE POINT ONE
MILLION ON THIS PRIMARILY HAS TO
DO WITH.
A CORRECTION IN OUR ESTIMATE
FROM CINEMA DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
STAFFING WHEN WE HAD COMPLETED
THE ESTIMATE ON PRIOR WE HAD
ANTICIPATED WHICH WE KNOW WE'RE
CLOSING DEVELOP THEM CINEMA BY
DECEMBER. IN THE LAST PERSON
WILL BE A MOVING OUT BY THAT
TIME WE HAD INCORRECTLY.
HAVES DAY YEAR SO WE DID A SIX
MONTH PROJECTION WE TOOK ANOTHER
HALF OFFER THAT WHEN WE DID THE
STAFFING PROJECTION. SO WE ONLY
PROJECTED AND THE.
ESTIMATE FOR US THREE MONTHS
WORTH OF STAFFING WHERE THIS.
PROVIDES A CORRECTION TO IT IT
ALLOWS THAN FOR THE SIX MONTHS
TO GET A THROUGH THE SUPPORTING
THE INDIVIDUAL THROUGH DECEMBER
UNTIL THE CLOSURE.
AND ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE
PROJECTED AND.
.
THE.
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER BUDGET IS
FOR THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
WHICH WILL BE SPEAKING TO I'M
SHORTLY REGARDING THE PROPOSAL
FOR THE SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND.
.
IT JUST BRIEFLY THEN ON
HEADQUARTERS THERE'S.
PRIMARILY TO TWO ITEMS IN THE.
HEADQUARTERS BUDGET ONE IS
REALLY RELATED TO THE ISSUE ONE
THAT YOU JUST HEARD ON THE OF.
ELECTRONIC.
VISIT VERIFICATION SO ARE ON
HEADQUARTERS BUDGET IT'S I'M
REQUESTING THE.
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
RELATED TO TWO POSITIONS TO HELP
FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
THAT WE ALSO HAVE A I REQUEST ON
PERSON CENTERED PLANNING ON THE
BCP. SO IT'S FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON TO ASSIST US
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
TRAINING AND BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS. I'M REALLY WITH
THE VISION I'M NOT GOING TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR. ON DEVELOPING
SERVICE PLANNING FOR INDIVIDUALS
CONSISTENT WITH THE FEDERAL I'M
RULES FOR PERSON CENTERED FOCUS
AND THINKING.
BUT WE DO SEE IT AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT ON THE
RACIAL CENTERS THE FAMILIES IN
THE CONSUMERS TO HAVE KIND OF A
FOUNDATION FOR WHERE THEY'RE
MOVING AND I'M HAVING ASSURANCE
THAT WE HAVE THE TRAINING THAT'S
CONSISTENT THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
TO ALLOW THEM TO KIND OF BUILD
FROM THAT FOR FUTURE.
I'M SO HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS OR WE CAN HAVE MISTER
DOYLE GO AHEAD AND ADDRESS THE
TWO ADDITIONAL ITEMS THAT WERE.
IN THE AGENDA FOR YOU.
I'M. MISTER DOYLE IF YOU WANT TO
GO TO THE BIGGER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR STAFF.
ON.
I WANTED TO.
JOHN DOYLE DEVELOPMENT SERVICES
JUST WANTED TO REITERATE WHAT
DIRECTOR BARGE BEEN SAID THE.
ADMINISTRATION IS CONTINUING
FORWARD WITH THE PROPOSAL TO
REINSTITUTE THE FOURTEEN DAY
UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE. AND
THE NUMBERS THAT ARE REFLECTED
IT MAY REVISION ARE THE SAME
ONES THAT YOU SAW ON MARCH SO.
THE ESTIMATE EMERGES CORRECTING
IT UP FOR THAT TIME PERIOD.
.
THE SECOND ISSUE THAT IS IN THE
AGENDA IS THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PLAN.
.
THE A BUDGET THE PROPOSED BUDGET
BILL CONTAINS CONTROL SECTION
SIX POINT ONE NO. WHICH INCLUDES
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
FOR A NUMBER OF STATE ENTITIES.
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES IS INCLUDED IN THAT
THEIR SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSED.
FOR PROJECTS AT THE PORTERVILLE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER.
AND THE CENTER WAS OPENED IN
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE SO IF YOU
CAN IMAGINE THERE'S THERE'S
PLENTY OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
WORK TO DO. ON THE TWO HUNDRED
AND ELEVEN BAD SECURE TREATMENT
PROGRAM AT PORTERVILLE IS GOING
TO CONTINUE ON IN OPERATION.
AND.
.
V. GENERAL TREATMENT PORTION OF
PORTABILITY SCHEDULED TO CLOSE
NO LATER THAN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
I'M WE'RE WE DON'T HAVE A LIST
YET OF THE FINAL PROJECTS THAT
WILL BE GOING FORWARD WERE STILL
WORKING ON THAT LIST.
BUT WE HAVE GROUP PROJECTS INTO
THREE MAJOR AREAS IT'S
BASICALLY.
ON ANY PROJECT THAT PROVIDES FOR
RESIDENT HEALTH AND SAFETY.
ANY ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROJECTS
AND THEN ANY ONGOING MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ELLIOTT.
SONYA PEDICLE JUST WAIT OF
ANALYST'S OFFICE. AND. WE HAVE
REVIEWED THE DEPARTMENTS OF HE
SLOWED.
ESTIMATES AND CORRESPONDING.
FISCAL.
UPDATES AND DO NOT HAVE ANY
REAL CONCERNS.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO REVIEW THE
LIST THAT THE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT PROVIDES WHEN WE GET
THAT INFORMATION OUR OFFICE HAD
SOME BROADER CONCERNS ABOUT THE
STATE'S OVERALL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROCESS AND. SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMPROVED
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN THOSE WILL BE HEARD AND SUB.
FOR.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO DTS IS
PROJECTS IN GENERAL.
IT MAKES SENSE THAT THEY'RE.
FOCUSING THEIR EFFORTS ON THE
FACILITY THAT WILL BE STAYING
OPEN.
GREAT.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE TO
.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BRIDGE WRECK ROLLAND
REPRESENTING ASSOCIATION
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES WILL BE
FOLLOWING UP WITH AN OFFICIAL
LETTER ON THE THE POSITIONS
OUGHT THAT ARE CAST ON ALL THE
ITEMS FOR TODAY BUT TED WANTED
TO. TALK ABOUT ITEM WHEN IT ONE
INTO IS THAT OKAY. SO ITEM ONE
ON THE.
CASELOAD ADJUSTMENTS A IN LIGHT
OF.
EXPENDITURE TRANSCEND BECAUSE
CASELOAD UPDATES A EXPENDITURES
ARE LOWER DUE TO INSUFFICIENT
PROVIDERS IN SOME CATEGORIES
ARGUABLY USE THAT RESERVE PEEL
US FUNDS. SHOULD BE REALLOCATED
FOR START UP OF NEW PROGRAMS.
AND ON ITEM NUMBER TWO THE HOME
HEALTH.
ICF A RATE INCREASES ARE WE ARE
SUPPORT TO THOSE RATE INCREASES
FOR ICF PROVIDERS THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU.
WELL SEVERAL FUTURES EXPORT AYE
RICIN.
SUPPORTERS RICK ROLLINS'S
COMMENTS ALSO THE ADJUSTMENT TO
NURSING SERVICES WILL BE HUGE
GODSEND FOR US AS ONE OF THE
TOUGHEST POSITIONS TO FILL FOR
FOLKS SIGNIFICANT MEDICAL NEEDS.
I DO EXPRESSED CONCERN ON THE
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS.
AS TO.
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE YES PART OF
THE SOUL IS GONNA STAY OPEN BUT
PARTS NOT.
SORRY PUTTING MONEY INTO PART OF
THE SALINAS GONNA CLOSE IN THREE
YEARS THAT SEEMS LIKE IT NOT A
GOOD USE OF STATE FUNDS.
THANK YOU SIR.
ONE MISTER CHAIR VERY JUTTING
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
SERVICES ASSOCIATION COUPLE
THINGS ONE ON THE UPDATE HE
KISSED LOW NUMBERS AYE ECHOED
RICK'S CONCERNS I'M WITH WITH
REGARDS TO THE DECREASE IN PART
IN SERVICE DOLLARS. A WEEK WE TO
BELIEVE THAT IT'S A RESULT OF
PROVIDERS NOT RECEIVING ADEQUATE
RATES THEREFORE NOT THERE NOT
BEING ENOUGH PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY SERVICES.
AND ALSO THE RESTRICTION ON
START UP SERVICES.
MAKE SURE THAT NEW PROVIDERS
DON'T GET INTO THE GAME SO WOULD
LOVE TO SEE THAT MONEY GO BACK
IN TO FIND FUND THOSE SERVICES.
ALSO JUST A NOTE ON THE UNIFORM
OF THE SCHEDULE YOU HEARD ALL
ABOUT OUR CONCERNS IN MARCH BUT
THE FACT THAT IT'S STILL IN THE
GOVERNOR'S ME REVISION IS A
SERIOUS CONCERN FOR US AND WE
WOULD HOPE THAT THAT WILL BE
TAKEN OUT BEFORE. ANY BUDGET IS
GREAT THANK YOU THINK SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND.
GIVE ME THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERSUS AYE JORDAN'S
WITH YOUR CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT ECHO THE COMMENTS
EARLIER ABOUT THE INCREASES DICE
YET DD'S. I'M ALSO WANNA ECHO
THE COMMENTS MADE BY MISTER
GIARDINI ABOUT THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE YOU'VE HEARD
OUR. CONCERNS WITHOUT AND ARE
OPPOSED TO THAT ALSO JUST
WONDERING ONE MORE ITEM WHICH
WOULDN'T BE OF MUCH USE
THE FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT ARE
LEFT ON THE TABLE. I DO DO THAT
CUT AND SO WE REALLY DO HOPE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WILL REJECT
A PROPOSAL THANK YOU THINK SIR.
I DON'T HAVE A HASN'T ON DISPLAY
RIGHT CALIFORNIA ECHOING THE
PAST COMMENTS ON THAT NURSING
RATES WHERE.
SUPPORT OF THOSE LIKE TO SEE
THAT HAPPENING ON THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE WE REMAIN
CONCERNED THAT'S ON THE BUDGET
TO THE EXTENT IT REMAINS WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THERE'S A CARVE OUT
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT SO THAT THEIR
EMPLOYMENT DOESN'T SUFFER. FOR
THE CONTEXT OF THE IN FROM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE THINKING.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
I UNDERSTAND MY EVIL TWIN WAS UP
HERE JUST A MOMENT AGO SO SORRY
I. I.
THOUGHT MAYBE YOU'RE JUST DOING
ITEMS ONE INTO BUT IF WE'RE
GONNA COVER ALL THE ITEMS IN THE
MAY REVISE HAVE CUT A COUPLE
OTHERS I'D LIKE TO BE ON RECORD
FOR THAT'S OKAY CORPORATE. ARMY
THINK SIR SO ITEM NUMBER OF FIVE
OF THE ICY FTD SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT PROGRAM ARE TO SUPPOSE
CUP A SUPPORTS THOSE PROPOSED
RATE INCREASES FOR THOSE
PROVIDERS ON IAN UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE WE REFER TO AS UNIFORM
FOR LOW DAY. SCHEDULE WE
TESTIFIED VERY STRONGLY ON BACK
IN FEBRUARY AGAINST THAT
PROPOSAL AND IT'S EVEN WORSE NOW
SINCE THERE'S SO MUCH MONEY
THAT'S COME INTO THE STATE ON OF
THROUGH THE MAY REVISE DOLLARS
THAT. HA WE FULLY HOPE THAT YOU
WILL REJECT THAT PROPOSAL. ARE
ALSO.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN.
.
OF IT A VENDOR'S COSTS IN
IMPLEMENTING ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION CRIMES NEED TO BE
BUDGET FOR THE FUTURE YEARS AS I
CANNOT BE OF ANOTHER. UNFUNDED
MANDATE A AND ITEM FOURTEEN ON
THE H. H. Q. CONTRACT CARCASS
SUPPORTS A PROPOSAL DO THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE PERSON CENTER
PRATT PLANNING. REGIONAL CENTERS
WILL NEED ADDITIONAL OPERATIONS
FUNDS AT SOME POINT AS WELL TO
ENHANCE A PERSON CENTERED
PLANNING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. IN
AGAIN WILL SEND YOU A LETTER
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENTS ON ISSUE TOO JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE WE GIVE EVERYONE
ENOUGH TIME.
FEEL FREE PLEASE.
THIRD.
YEAH.
WELL.
THANK YOU.
EVELYNOF US AND THAT'S WHERE
IT'S COMING ON THE PERSON
CENTERED PLANNING PIECE WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. FAMILY
MEMBERS CONSUMERS ARE ALL
ENGAGED IN THE PROCESS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR INPUT IS
CONSIDERED AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THAT WITH THAT PIECE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
SINGLE FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
OFF BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS.
.
THANK YOU FOR THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY WILL GET BACK WITH YOU
I WANTED TO SHARE THE SERIOUS
CONCERN REGARDING THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE ALL IT WILL BE.
SOMETHING WE AS A LEGISLATURE
TAKEN UP STRONG LOOK AT.
AND WE MAY RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH THE POSITION OF
THE ADMINISTRATION AND.
WILL BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
AND FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN BEST
PROCEED.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE TO
OPEN IN THE BOND ISSUE THREE
YEAH.
BAD JUDGEMENT BUT OKAY.
WHEN YOU'RE READY THAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF PITCHER VANKO
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AGAIN ARE I'M HAPPY TO
GO THROUGH AND AS MUCH OR AS
LITTLE DETAIL AS YOU'D LIKE CARE
SAW START WITH VERY LITTLE AND
YOU TELL ME IF YOU'D LIKE A
LITTLE BIT MORE.
IS SENSUALLY.
I ISSUE THREE REFLECTS A THE
NORMAL CASELOAD ADJUSTMENTS FOR
THEM A REVISION. ACROSS THE
BOARD CASELOADS ARE FALLING IN A
IN A VIRTUALLY ALL OF OUR
PROGRAMS.
THERE ARE SOME COST INCREASES
ARE PARTICULARLY IN THE AYE CHU
SASS PROGRAM ALTHOUGH CASELOAD
IS DOWN SLIGHTLY FROM WHAT WE
PROJECTED IT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
IT'S STILL RISING A LITTLE BIT.
OF AN ATHORIZED HOURS PER CASE.
AND.
THE CAUGHT THE COST PER HOUR
ARE AND CONTINUE TO INCREASE
THEIR. A ES ASIDE ASSIST P.
CONTINUES TO TRY AND VERY
SLIGHTLY DOWN THAT'S IN LINE
WITH A NATIONAL COMPARISONS OF
THAT THAT CASELOAD AS WELL.
IN CAL WORKS ARE WE'RE
PROJECTING TO HIT A RECORD LOW
CASELOADS.
GOT GOING AHEAD BY THE END OF
THE BUDGET HERE.
.
THE TABLE ON PAGE THIRTEEN AND
FOURTEEN OF YOUR AGENDA
ACCURATELY REFLECTS THAT THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE REQUESTED IN
TERMS OF BASELINE ADJUSTMENTS.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THERE OR I CAN
CONTINUE.
COULDN'T.
ALRIGHT.
OTHER BIG THE FIRST ISSUE OF THE
FIRST ITEM ON PAGE FOURTEEN IS A
COW WORK SINGLE ALLOCATION IN IN
THE MAY REVISIONIST COMMITTED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
WE'VE IMPLEMENTED EVAN AMINU
METHODOLOGY FOR THE ELIGIBILITY
COMPONENT OF THE CAL WORKS
SINGLE ALLOCATION.
IT ALSO.
PROVIDES.
IS SOME STABILITY FOR FOR
COUNTY OPERATIONS IT RECOGNIZES%
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN FIXED
COSTS AND VARIABLE COSTS.
IN IN THE A FUNDING ALLOCATION
AND PROPOSES THAT GOING FORWARD.
CASELOADS AND AND COST NEED TO
ADJUST BY FIVE PERCENT.
EITHER UP OR DOWN BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY ADJUST THE
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDING IT
PROVIDES A LEVEL OF CERTAINTY
BUT ALSO ACCOUNTS FOR ANY MAJOR
ADJUSTMENTS IN AND WHAT IT TAKES
TO OPERATE THE PROGRAM.
ELIGIBILITY WITHIN THE SINGLE
ALLOCATION IS JUST ONE COMPONENT
OTHER COMPONENTS INCLUDE
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AND OTHER
THINGS AND METHODOLOGIES WILL
CONTINUE TO BE DEVELOPED.
IN INTO THE BUDGET YEAR.
FOR THOSE.
PRESUMABLY FOR PRESENTATION TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE COMING
FALL BUT IT'S BEEN.
HEAVILY COLLABORATIVE EFFORT.
WITH COUNTIES AND AND.
AND.
SEE SACRISTAN ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND WE'D
LIKE TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR ARE
GOING BACK AND FORTH WITH US ON
THAT.
.
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO GO THROUGH
ALL THE ITEMS YEAH BUT I'LL DO
THEM ALL AT ONCE SO ON PAGE
FIFTEEN ITEM TO A HOUSING
SUPPORT PROGRAM THE BASS FUNDING
FOR THIS PROGRAM IS AROUND FORTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. OF
THE MAYOR OF VISION PROPOSES TO
INCREASE STOP BY TWENTY FOUR
MILLION IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
WITH ANOTHER SUBSEQUENT
ADJUSTMENT OF A SIMILAR AMOUNT
IN THE FOLLOWING YEAR TO BRING
THE PROGRAM UP TO A TOTAL OF
NINETY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AND
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR. A GOING FORWARD WE THINK.
AT IT'S NO SECRET TO ANYBODY
THAT HOUSING IS A CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THIS PROGRAM
PROVIDE SOME VITAL ASSISTANCE TO
FAMILIES AND IN FORM OF BOTH
EMERGENCY SHELTER ASSISTANCE
ABOUT A MORE MORE IMPORTANTLY AS
STABLE LIVING ARRANGEMENTS
RENTAL SUBSIDIES AND THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS.
COUPLED WITH THAT I KNOW THAT
THE THIRD ITEM HERE IS AN
INCREASE IN THE AILY RATE FOR
THE HOMELESS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES A NINE
NIGHTLY RATE FOR A SHELTER FOR.
UP TO SIXTEEN DAYS FOR A ONCE A
YEAR.
I THERE'S A PIECE OF TRAILER
BILL TO GO ALONG WITH THAT
BECAUSE THIS RATE IS SET IN
STATUTE OF THE RATE WOULD BE
PROPOSED TO THE STATE AND IN THE
AGENDA TO GO FROM. SIXTY FIVE
DOLLARS A NIGHT TO EIGHTY FIVE
DOLLARS A NIGHT AND I BELIEVE
THE LAST TIME IT WAS INCREASED
WAS TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT.
AND SO I HAVE PROUD TO BE ABLE
TO INCLUDE THAT.
ON PAGE SIXTEEN ITEM FOR ON THE
HOME SAFE PROGRAM THIS IS A
PROPOSED A FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR AUGMENTATION. TO ADDRESS
OUR THE NEEDS OF.
SENIORS WHO WERE INVOLVED WITH
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES. AGAIN
RELATED TO HOUSING GETTING THEM
AND POTENTIALLY OUT OF AN
ABUSIVE SITUATION OR HELPING
THEM.
IF THEY'RETRYING TO REMAIN
INDEPENDENT TO TO DO SO.
OTHERS ALSO SOME OUR FORTHCOMING
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON THAT
AND WE'VE HAD SOME OF
COLLABORATION ON THE DROPS THERE
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
IN THE AYE H. ASSESS PROGRAM.
ITEM FIVE IN THE AGENDA A WE
PROPOSE DE A NEW METHODOLOGY
HERE AGAIN IS SPENT A LOT OF
INTENSIVE COLLABORATION WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES. AND AS STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
ON.
DATA IS COMPLICATED.
WE CONTINUE TO MEET WITH THEM.
NOW TO DISCUSS THE DATA USED
UNDERLYING THE METHODOLOGY.
WE OF COURSE FEEL CONFIDENT IN
WHAT WE WE HAVE PROVIDED BUT.
ALSO OPEN TO OTHER OPINIONS I
THINK OUR NEXT MEETING WE'RE
TRYING TO SCHEDULE IS FOR THIS
FRIDAY. REALIZING THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT FOR THE
TIMING OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE. ON
BUT WE THINK WE'RE LARGELY THERE
THE DIFFERENCE THAT REMAINS IS
IS RELATIVELY MINOR.
ALTHOUGH IMPORTANT.
FILE ITEM SIX IS.
AB EIGHTY FIVE SAVINGS.
WITH THE EXPANSION OF A CA A
CREATED A LOCAL SAVINGS FOR
INDIGENT HEALTH CARE THIS IS A
JUST ROUTINE ADJUSTMENT TO THAT
THE FUNDING ASSUMPTIONS.
BEHIND THE VARIOUS FUND SOURCES
FOR THAT PROGRAM.
THE NEXT COUPLE OF ITEMS ARE
ARE ALL RELATED TO THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE REFORM WHICH IS
CALIFORNIA'S.
REFORM TO THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM THAT WE'VE BEEN. UNDER
WAY.
ON SINCE AT TWENTY ELEVEN.
.
THEY'RE A COUPLE ITEMS HERE. A
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL THIS IS
THE PROCESS THAT WE USED TO
APPROVE HOME SAYS PLACEMENTS FOR
PEOPLE.
IT'S NEW IT'S DIFFICULT FOLKS
ARE LEARNING.
AND WE'VE DEVELOPED A BACKLOG
IN THE APPROVAL PROCESS THERE
WE'VE PROVIDED A AS STATED IN
THE AGENDA.
NEARLY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
TO ADDRESS THAT BACKLOG ON A
ONE TIME BASIS A TICK.
TO TO RESOLVE THAT AND WE DON'T
WANT IMPEDIMENTS TO PLACEMENTS
TO OCCUR.
IT IT ITEM EIGHT.
KIT CAREGIVER ASSISTANCE
PAYMENTS.
WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK ON
TRAILER BILL FOR THIS PROPOSAL
AS WELL YOU MAY RECALL IN THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR WE PASSED A
WITH THE LEGISLATURE URGENCY
LEGISLATION A AB ONE TANNED. A
TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
FAMILIES.
TYPICALLY ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
FEDERAL FUNDING UNTIL YOUR HOME
HAS BEEN APPROVED AND BECAUSE OF
THE LENGTHY APPROVAL PROCESS
FAMILIES WERE BEING ASKED TO
TAKE CARE OF CHILDREN OF FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS AT A TIME WITHOUT
PAYMENT. THAT PROOF OF SHORT
TERM SOLUTION EXPIRES JUNE
THIRTY AND SO WE'RE PROPOSING.
TO CONTINUE A METHOD TO ENSURE
THAT PAYMENTS CAN BE MATT.
GOING FORWARD THROUGH BUDGET
YEAR AND ON GOING THIS IS WHAT
WE CALL THE LONG TERM SOLUTION.
THE LOOK OF CARE ASSESSMENT TOOL
THIS IS THE CHILD ASSESSMENT
THAT HELPS.
IDENTIFIED THE RATE THAT'S
APPROPRIATE TO MEET THE.
KAREN SUPERVISION NEEDS OF THE
CHILD.
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS IS A
NEW ACTIVITY AND WE'RE PROPOSING
A COMBINATION OF FUN SOURCES IN
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION AND COUNTY USE OF
THAT TOOL.
ITEM TEN REFLECTS.
AT AN ADJUSTMENT TO THE A
TRANSFER OF CHILDREN FOR AN
YOUTH FROM GRUPOM SETTINGS TO
HOME BASE FAMILY CARE SETTINGS.
AND THIS.
IS.
CASE I WOULD CONSIDER THIS A
CASELOAD UPDATE AND AN
IMPORTANT.
TO NOTE.
IT'S BASED ON THE MOST RECENT
DATA AND EXPERIENCE THAT WE HAVE
THOSE TRANSITIONS ARE GOING
SLOWER THAN WE HAD PLANNED.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS NEW AND
DIFFICULT AND WITH THE DELAY IN
APPROVAL OF HOMES THAT OBVIOUSLY
IMPACTS THE ABILITY TO TAKE
CHILDREN FROM CONGREGATE KAREN
AND PUT THEM IN A HOME BASE
FAMILY CARE SETTINGS?
SO THAT THAT'S A MOVING SLOWER.
AS WELL THE SPECIALIZED CARE
INCREMENTING ITEM ELEVEN.
IN ADDITION TO THE RATE PAID BY
THE STATE COUNTY WELFARE
AGENCIES.
ALSO PROVIDE HISTORICALLY A
SPECIALIZED CARE INCREMENTAL BY
OF THE RATE WHEN THE NEEDS OF
THE CHILD INDICATE.
THAT THAT ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
ARE NEEDED FUNDING FOR THAT WAS
REALIGNED AND IN RECOGNITION OF
THE NEW RATE STRUCTURE UNDER THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM.
COUNTY PLANS A ARE ACTUALLY
SUBMIT I THINK THEY WERE DO
YESTERDAY TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
REFLECTING ADJUSTMENTS TO THEIR
SPECIALIZED CARE INCREMENT
POLICIES. ARE GOING FORWARD AND
SO.
WE'VE ADJUSTED THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ASSUMPTION ABOUT ANY
OFFSETS TO THOSE SPECIALIZED
CARE INCREMENTS.
ON ITEM TWELVE THIS IS AT A
TRIBAL ISSUE AT THE REQUEST OF
SOME TRIBES WE HAVE TWO TRIBES
IN CALIFORNIA. THAT HAVE
EXISTING OF FEDERAL A TITLE FOR
E. AGREEMENTS THIS ALLOWS THEM
TO DRAW. A OPERATE THEIR OWN
CHILD WELFARE PROGRAMS AT THE
TRIBAL LEVEL RATHER THAN VIA THE
COUNTY.
.
AND WITH ANYTHING DO IT'S A
LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT TO START UP
AND NOT ALL OF THE STAFF COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE STARTUP
ACTIVITIES. ARE NECESSARILY
CLAIM MOBILE AGAINST A
PARTICULAR CHILD WELFARE CASE
AND SO.
AT WHERE YOU ARE PROPOSING.
MY MINOR AMOUNT OF FUNDING TO
PROVIDE START UP FOR THEM TO PAY
THEIR STAFF TO GET THEIR
PROGRAMS UP AND RUNNING.
ON AT THE LAST ITEM ON PAGE
SEVENTEEN THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS THAT ARE LISTED ON PAGE
EIGHTEEN. INCLUDING THE.
FOSTER PARENT RETENTION
RECRUITMENT AND SUPPORT PROGRAM
CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMING CASE
RECORD REVIEWS. A COMMERCIALLY
SEXUALLY EXPLOITED CHILDREN'S
PROGRAM FOR WHICH WE'RE
PROPOSING TO TO A RE APPROPRIATE
AN EXPANDED PRIOR YEAR FUNDING
THAT WAS APPROPRIATED FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS.
NON.
AND THE LAST ISSUE ON PAGE.
.
AND IT'S NOT THE LAST ISSUE
SORRY.
OF THE.
THE ISSUE AT THE TOP OF PAGE
NINETEEN AS DISASTER ASSISTANCE.
IN A DISASTER OUR DEPARTMENT
HAS RESPONSIBILITY FOR MASS
KAREN SHELTER OBLIGATIONS THE
FIRST RECOURSE FOR PEOPLE
IMPACTED BY DISASTERS IS TO GO
THROUGH THE FEMALE PROCESS.
BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY'VE
EXHAUSTED WHAT FEMA HOUSE TO
OFFER THE STATE HAS A
SUPPLEMENTAL A GRANT PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES UP TO TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS. TO FURTHER MEET THOSE
NEEDS WE'VE PAID APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED CASES AS A RESULT OF
WILDFIRES AND OTHER ACTIVITIES
THIS YEAR. AND REQUESTED A MINOR
AMOUNT OF FUNDING.
TO.
.
PAY FOR THE COST OF THOSE
GRANTS.
.
THE TRAILER BILL PROPOSALS IN
ADDITION TO THOSE THAT WERE
MENTIONED. IN MY EARLIER
COMMENTS
HOME BASED FAMILY RATES.
FOUR FAMILIES WITH PLACEMENTS
BETWEEN AT TWENTY ELEVEN AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN FOR.
.
ADOPTION ASSISTANCE CAN GAP
BAND AND NON RELATED LEGAL
GUARDIANS.
A WE WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT THE
RATES THOSE FAMILIES ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR IS THE RATE THAT
WAS AT IN EXISTENCE AT THE TIME
THE PLACEMENT WAS AGREED UPON.
AND NOT THE NEW HOME BASED
FAMILY CARE RATE.
THAT'S A CONSISTENT WITH PAST
PRACTICE IN THE PROGRAM AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS LANGUAGE DOES I
HEAR IF THERE'S A CHANGE IN
CIRCUMSTANCES ON THE CHILD IS
REASSESSED AND THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASSESS THE HIGHER
RATE.
BUT THE BUDGET DOES NOT INCLUDE
FUNDING TO RETROACTIVELY
INCREASED THE RATE SYDNEY'S
PLACEMENT TYPES BACK FIVE YEARS.
ROOM
AND SAID THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF TRAILER DAHLE
FOR.
BECAUSE STAYING WITHIN.
APPROPRIATED RESOURCES.
AND THEN ITEM SIXTEEN IS
EXACTLY IS TITLED ITS FEDERAL
COMPLIANCE WITH THE RULE MAKING
THAT WAS DONE IN AN HOUR RICK AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL REGARDING THE
INDIAN CHILD WELFARE ACT AND IN
CUSTODY PROCEEDINGS CLARIFYING
THE ROLE OF TRIBES IN THOSE
PROCEEDINGS.
ON.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT DUE TO THE
NATURE OF THAT THE BUDGET
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS TRIBES HAVE
NOT YET HAD A CHANCE TO SEE THAT
AND. LANGUAGE AND KIND. AND.
CONFIRMED THAT IT MEETS THEIR
NEEDS ABOUT THAT CONSULTATION IT
IS HAPPENING I IN MEETINGS ARE
BEGINNING TODAY. ON AND WE DON'T
THINK THEY'LL FIND.
SUBSTANTIAL CONCERNS WITH THAT
LANGUAGE.
I WILL CEASE DOT THERE WITH
THOSE BUT IF I COULD MAKE ONE
GENERAL REMARKS FOR THE RECORD
ACROSS EVERYTHING HEARD IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
DUE TO THE NUMBER OF.
PROPOSALS IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS YEAR.
WHAT ONCE DECISIONS BECOME A
LITTLE BIT MORE CLEAR AROUND
WHAT THE PACKAGE LOOKS LIKE WE'D
LIKE TO REQUEST THAT THE
COMMITTEE ALLOW US TO ENGAGE
WITH STAFF AND BRING FORWARD A
PROPOSAL? DEBTS CONSOLIDATED AND
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE STATE
OPERATIONS NEEDS TO EFFECTUATE A
NUMBER OF THESE PROGRAMS THERE'S
A LOT OF NEW CONTRACTS RATE
ADJUSTMENTS CONSULTATION THAT
HAS TO HAPPEN THERE'S A VARIETY
OF HOUSING PROPOSALS FOR
EXAMPLE.
AND IT'S DIFFICULT TO ANALYZE
THE STATE OPS NEEDS FOR EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF THOSE BUT IF WE
KNOW THERE ARE THREE OR FOUR IN
A SUBJECT AREA WE'D LIKE TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REVISIT STATE
OPERATIONS. IE STAFF FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO MAKE THESE THINGS
HAPPEN NEGOTIATE THAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
LA A.
GOOD MORNING CHAD ALAMO WITH THE
LA JOH WE COVERED A LOT OF
MATERIAL JUST AND SO WILL KIND
OF GO BACK AND FORTH AS WE. AS
WE HIT OUR OUR TOPICS.
REGARDING THAT THE COW WORKS
CASELOAD ADJUSTMENTS FOR THE MAY
REVISE OUR OFFICE HAS REVIEWED
THE ADMINISTRATION'S UPDATED
NUMBERS ON AND IN FACT HAVE VERY
SIMILAR CASE OF FORECASTS
OURSELVES WE THINK THEY'RE
REASONABLE.
THAT THE BIGGEST CHANGE.
FROM GOVERNOR'S BUDGET MAY
REVISE IN THE CAO WORKS PROGRAM
IS THE NEW METHODOLOGY THAT'S
USED IN THE SINGLE ALLOCATION
FOR THE ELIGIBILITY COMPONENT.
ON THE WORD JUST BEGINNING OUR
REVIEW OF THE METHODOLOGY WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
ON AS WELL THE PART OF FINANCE
AND COUNTY STAKEHOLDER SPENT
CONSIDERABLE TIME. THIS LAST
YEAR ON PUTTING TOGETHER A NEW
METHODOLOGY THE PRELIMINARY LOOK
SUGGEST THAT IT'S GOING TO BE AN
IMPROVEMENT OVER PAST PRACTICE
I'M WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION THE LEARN
MORE ABOUT THAT.
MOVING ONTO THAT THE TO HOUSING
PROPOSALS THAT THAT REPRESENT.
TO PORTIONS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE OUT THERE
EXPANSION OF EXISTING PROGRAMS
AND THE COWARDS PROGRAM AND AND
TO OUR OFFICE SEEM REASONABLE.
.
OF.
MOVING ALONG AT A.
WITH REGARDS TO THE I JUST AS
PROGRAM THE MAIN DRIVERS FOR
THAT BASS ADJUSTMENTS A ROUTE
FROM MAY REVISE RELATIVE TO THE
JANUARY HAVE TO DO WITH HIGHER
HOURS PER CASE HIGHER PROVIDER
COSTS AND HIGHER OVERTIME COSTS.
I'M WE RECEIVE SOME BACKUP FROM
THE DEPARTMENT YESTERDAY AND ARE
CONTINUING TO REVIEW THE DATA
BUT AT THIS TIME REYES NO
CONCERNS WITH THOSE ADJUSTMENTS
WITH REGARDS TO THAT I JUST SAYS
THAT ADMIN COSTS. COMPONENT IT'S
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT WAS
MAINLY AN ADJUSTMENT TO REFLECT
NEW ASSUMPTIONS AROUND BENEFIT
COSTS. AND.
OVERHEAD COSTS AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL AS THE DEPARTMENT NOTED
THERE CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS TO
LOOK AT THE METHODOLOGY AND IT'S
OUR UNDERSTANDING IN JANUARY THE
ADMINISTRATION DID SAY THAT AS A
PART OF THEIR TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. BUDGET THAT THEY
WOULD ALSO BE REVIEWING THAT THE
METHODOLOGY AND TO ENSURE THAT
TO THE EXTENT THAT ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL CHANGES NEED TO BE
MADE THAT THE REFLECTED.
AND JUST BRIEFLY THANK YOU FOR.
REGARDING THE AB EIGHTY FIVE
SAVINGS ESTIMATE REVISIONS IN
THE MAY REVISE.
LIKE APARTMENTS AT THIS
REPRESENTS INCREASED.
OFFSETTING SAVINGS.
.
RESULTING FROM INDIGENT CARE
SAVINGS RELATES THE A CA ARM
WHICH HAD THE EFFECT OF REDUCING
GENERAL FUND COSTS FOR THE CAO
WORKS PROGRAM OUT WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH A
PARTNER FINANCE TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE DYNAMICS OF THAT
UPDATED. I ESTIMATE BUT BUT SO
FAR IT SEEMS TOTALLY REASONABLE
TO.
BEN JOHNSON WITH THE LA SHOW.
HERE ON ITEM SEVEN OF THE RFA
BACKLOG FUNDING.
DO THINK IT MAKES SENSE IN
CONCEPT OF PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO CLEAR BACKLOGS WE DID
RAISE QUESTIONS IN OUR.
INITIAL COMMENTS ON THAT.
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL THAT THE CASELOAD
ESTIMATE.
OR THAT BACKLOG ESTIMATE.
DIFFERED IN THE MAY REVISION AS
OPPOSED TO PREVIOUS DATA THAT WE
HAD SEEN FROM THE DEPARTMENT OUR
SUBSEQUENT UNDERSTANDING.
AFTER WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IS THAT.
THE FUNDING IS ONLY TO ADDRESS
A A PORTION OF THE EXISTING
BACKLOG NAMELY THE.
FOSTER CARE GIVERS WITH WHOM
CHILDREN ARE ALREADY PLACED ON
AN EMERGENCY BASIS SO IT WOULD
NOT ADDRESS THE BACKLOG FOR SAY
A NEW FOSTER CARE GIVER THAT'S
YOU KNOW COMING TO COMING INTO
THE PROGRAM AND AND WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE A FOSTER CHILD.
UNRELATED SAY.
INTO THEIR HOME AND SO THAT
BACKPACK LOG COULD CONTINUE TO
EXIST AND COULD CONTINUE TO.
STYMIE SOME OF THE EFFORTS TO
INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY OF
HOME BASE PLACEMENTS.
I'M ON ITEM EIGHT A WE DO.
WELCOME THE CONCEPT OF FUNDING
FOR.
PAYMENTS AT THE TIME OF
PLACEMENT AS PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR WE HAVE NOT SEEN THE
TRAILER BILL YET HOWEVER I AND
WILL REVIEW AND PROVIDE ANY
COMMENTS AS WE SEE A AS WE SEE
THE A THE TRAILER BILL. ON LOC.
DO WE WE RAISE THIS IN OUR
JANUARY ANALYSIS THAT DOES SOME
FUNDING COULD BE NECESSARY IN
ORDER TO MEET OUR PROP THIRTY
OBLIGATIONS.
AND SO WERE LOKING AT THE
FUNDING ABOUT AND SO FORTH AND
EVALUATING THAT AND I'M.
BUT ARE ALSO ASKING THE
DEPARTMENT ON THE CANS
ASSESSMENT THAT IS NEWLY GONNA
BE REQUIRED UNDER IT SHE SEE
ARE.
WHETHER OR NOT.
FUNDING FOR THAT ISRAELI
ADEQUATELY SORT OF SUBSUMED IN
FUNDING THAT THE.
THAT THE STATE RD PROVIDE STAY
COUNTY WELFARE DEPARTMENTS BOTH
IN THE FORM OF REALIGNMENT
FUNDING SO THE CASE PLANNING
ACTIVE ACT ACTIVITIES FUNDING
THAT WOULD STATUS PROVIDED SINCE
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN AS WELL AS.
NEW FUNDING FOR CHILD FAMILY
TEAMS OR JUST WORKING TO SEE HOW
THOSE NUMBERS COP TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE STATE THAT IS
ADEQUATELY FUNDING IT'S IT'S
PROP THIRTY OBLIGATIONS.
WE DO NOTE IN OUR.
IN OUR RIGHT UP THAT THE ON
ITEM TEN ACTUALLY I'LL JUST SAY
ITEMS TEN AND ELEVEN THAT DATA A
NEW BUDGET DOES REFLECT UPDATED
CASELOAD PROJECTIONS.
WHICH DOES RESULT IN HIGHER
GENERAL FUND FUND COSTA OF I
THINK A LOT OF THOSE END UP IN
THE IN THE BUDGET YEAR SO
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN
PREVIOUSLY ESTIMATED.
AND THAT THE SEC AT THAT
SPECIALIZED KAREN COMMIT SAVINGS
ADJUSTMENT APPROPRIATELY REMOVED
FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
SINCE WE REALLY DON'T THINK ANY
A ADJUSTMENTS WELL. UP UP THERE
ARE IT'S UNLIKELY THAT MAJOR
ADJUSTMENTS WILL BE OCCURRING IN
THE ESSAY I IN IN THE CURRENT
YEAR.
WE DO THINK THAT THERE IS SOME
RISK THAT THERE COULD BE SOME
UNDER FUNDING IN THE BUDGET YEAR
SHOULD REDUCTIONS IN SPECIALIZED
CARE AMPLE IN INCREMENTS NOT
OCCUR AS QUICKLY AS US
DOOMED AS THE DEPARTMENT.
ASSUMING AND WE ARE LOOKING
INTO THE ESTIMATE METHODOLOGY
AND THERE'S.
TO SEE IF THERE IS SOME RISK
THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
OVERESTIMATING SAVINGS WHICH
COULD RESULT IN A ULTIMATELY IN
HIGHER COSTS OUT IN THE BUDGET
YEAR WHICH WOULD. ULTIMATELY
HAVE TO BE PAID BY THE STATE SO.
WE DON'T RAISE ANY OTHER
CONCERNS ON THE.
ON THE OTHER PROPOSALS HERE ON
THE CHILD WELFARE SIDE.
THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE THREE ANY. PORTION OF
THIS PLEASE JUST IDENTIFIES SO
THAT. WE KNOW WHICH ISSUE WHERE
SECTION HEARD DISCUSSED.
CAN KESSLER WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES ON ITEM FIVE WHICH
IS THE COMBINATION OF COUNTY AD
MAN AND PUBLIC AUTHORITY AD MAN
WE WERE VERY CONCERNED.
IN WHERE PUBLIC AUTHORITIES
HAVE LANDED WHEN THE STATE
COUNTY FINANCIAL RELATIONSHIP
CHANGED UNDER THE NEW MOE WE
LOST OVER A QUARTER OF THE ADMIN
DOLLARS. FOR PUBLIC AUTHORITIES
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
WORKING VERY HARD WITH US SINCE
JANUARY TO CONSTRUCT A NEW
BUDGET WORKLOAD FORMULA AND THIS
FOR US WAS BRAND NEW TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW MANY STAFF IT
TAKES. TO FULFILL OUR MANDATES
TO PROJECT NUMBER ONE WAS TO
IDENTIFY THE THINGS AND STATUTES
THAT WE THE PUBLIC AUTHORITIES
HAVE TO DO OUR MANDATES AND TO
SEPARATE TAT FROM. COUNTY
MANDATES I MENTION THAT BECAUSE
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF COUNTIES
THAT HAVE THEIR PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES TO PROVIDER
ENROLLMENT SOME THAT HAVE THEIR
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES HANDLE
PAYROLL.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT WHERE
WE HAVE COME OUT IN THIS IS
HARDLY UNUSUAL FOR YOU TO HEAR
IS AN ABSOLUTELY FAIR WAYTO
FUND PUBLIC AUTHORITIES WE
APPRECIATE THE MAY REVISED
EDITION OF ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION. WE THINK THAT THEIR
FORMULA IS INTELLECTUAL FARE AND
THAT THEIR PROCESS WAS
TRANSPARENT.
SO IN TERMS OF OUR PUBLIC
AUTHORITY MANDATES WE CAME OUT
IN A VERY OKAY PLACE SO LONG AS
YOU APPROVE THE MAY REVISE ON
THE COUNTY ADMIN SIGN I JUST
DECIDED WANTED TO SAY THAT.
THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
COUNTIES HAVE CONCERNS ON THE
ADEQUACY OF THEIR FUNDING IT
AFFECTS THEIR CAPACITY TO BEN
CONTRACT WITH THE PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR THINGS LIKE
PROVIDER ENROLLMENT AND SO
FORTH.
THAT'S REALLY MORRISSEY SAKON CW
DE A ISSUE BUT I WON'T LET YOU
KNOW THAT THERE IS AN INTERPLAY
SO AGAIN OUR THANKS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION THEY'VE REALLY
BEEN SOLID PARTNERS. ARM AND OUT
AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
MAY REVISE
THANK YOU MA'AM AND I'M JUST
GONNA PAUSE PUBLIC COMMENT JUST
FOR A SECOND SO THAT WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA PRESENT HARPER.
MATHIS RUBIO HERE.
DOCTOR WOULD.
QUORUM.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS ROBERT HARRIS ON
BEHALF SEIU CALIFORNIA.
WE APPRECIATE THE COUNTY. ADMIN
WORK THE SPEND ON WE THINK IT'S
INCOMPLETE BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
ALLOW. FOR THE TRUE COST OF THE
SOCIAL WORKERS WHO ACTUALLY ARE
THAT MOST.
SOME OF THE HIGHER PAID AND MORE
SKILLED SOCIAL WORKERS WHO DO
THIS.
AND WHEN WHEN THAT DOESN'T
FACTORY INCORRECTLY BENNETT LOOK
PUTS PRESSURE DOWNWARD PRESSURE.
FIRST FROM THE COUNTIES AND TO
THE PUBLIC AUTHORITIES.
THEN TO HAVE IT.
THAT I JUST ASK WORKERS AND THEN
ULTIMATELY ON THE RECIPIENTS OF
THE SERVICES.
WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT SO JOE WE
THINK THAT WE'RE GLAD TO HEAR
THEY'RE WORKING ON ON COMING UP
WITH A BETTER ESTIMATE? THE
OTHER THING THAT'S MISSING IN
THE END THIS IS ACOSTA LIVING IF
YOU DON'T DO A COCA COLA. AND
NEXT YEAR IT ENDS UP BEYOND.
THAT DOWNWARD PRESSURE AGAIN AND
AND WE THINK THAT'S JUST WRONG
AND WE THINK THAT THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE COUNTIES CAN ACTUALLY
COME UP WITH THE REAL COST OF
WHAT A SOCIAL WORKER COSTS IN
THIS AREA. AND THEN COME UP WITH
A SLIGHTLY INCREASED THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT WILL. REACH
ACCURATELY REFLECT THE TRUE
COSTS OF DOING THE ADMINSTRATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FRANK
MECCA EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION FIRST I WANNA SAY
THAT WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF AN VERY
THANKFUL FOR THE HOUSING
RELATED.
AUGMENTATION SUMMIT SENT LETTERS
INTO THE COMMITTEE TO THAT
EFFECT WE'RE VERY PLEASED THAT
THAT GOVERNOR INCLUDED THAT
FUNDING IN THE MAY REVISION. WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE ENGAGEMENT
WITH THE DEPARTMENT ON A NUMBER
OF IMPORTANT OUT BUDGETING
METHODOLOGIES FOR OUR MINISTRY
OF WORK ASSOCIATED WITH CCR WITH
I JUST AS SOME WITH CAL WORKS.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING IN VERY GOOD
FAITH WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
TRY TO TRUE THOSE UP TO WHAT IT
ACTUALLY COST TO DO THOSE JOBS.
THERE ARE A HANDFUL OF ISSUES
THAT YOU'VE HEARD ALREADY TODAY
WHERE WE DO TAKE EXCEPTION TO
THE MAY REVISE AND WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. I'M WITH RESPECT TO
THE CAL WORK SINGLE ALLOCATION
AND WE HAD A TERRIFIC ENGAGEMENT
TO SORT OF TRUE UP. WHAT IT COST
TO DO THE ELIGIBILITY PORTION OF
THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM AND WE WE
HAVE ACTUALLY NO CONCERNS WITH
WHERE THAT LANDED?
WHAT HAPPENED THOSE BETWEEN
JANUARY AND MAY THERE WAS A
FURTHER CASELOAD REDUCTION THAT
WAS TAKEN? ASSOCIATED WITH THE
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
WHICH IS THE NEXT COMPONENT THAT
WE'RE TACKLING WITH THE STATE TO
TRUE UP. WHAT WE'RE ASKING IS
THAT IN THE MEANTIME UNTIL WE
CAN FIGURE OUT A BETTER
METHODOLOGY FOR EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES WE NOT FURTHER TAKE A
CUT OF ABOUT TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS? WHICH WOULD BE ON TOP
OF ALMOST THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE PRIOR.
TWO AND A HALF YEARS SO WE
BASICALLY WANT TO STOP THE
BLEEDING. AND BE HELD HARMLESS
UNTIL WE CONTROL UP THE
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES METHODOLOGY.
WITH RESPECT TO I JUST AS
ADMINISTRATION WE SIMILARLY HAVE
A.
A POSITION IN THAT WE CAME TO
AN AGREEMENT ON HOW MUCH WORK IS
IT TO DO I ASSESS THERE'S NO
DISAGREEMENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND. THE QUESTION
THAT WE'RE STILL TALKING ABOUT
RIGHT NOW IS.
HOW MUCH IS AN HOUR OF SOCIAL
WORK COST
IT'S AN EMPIRICAL QUESTION IT'S
NOT A THING THAT WERE?
SPECULATING ON BUT THERE'S A A
METHODOLOGY THAT ADMINISTRATION
USED WHICH WAS TO GO TO COUNTY
WEBSITES AND LOOK AT PUBLISHED
SALARY RANGES AND PICKED A
MIDPOINT. AND ASSUME THAT THAT'S
KIND OF WHAT.
PEOPLE SHOULD BE GETTING IN THAT
REGION.
AND WE POLL DATA THAT FROM
ACTUAL COUNTY COSTS
WHICH WE THINK IS A SUPERIOR
METHODOLOGY. THERE SOME
REFINEMENTS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS I'M ASKING
FOR IS AS LATE AS LAST NIGHT'S
WE'RE GONNA KEEP.
WORKING WITH THEM.
BUT WE BELIEVE OUR METHODOLOGY
SIGNIFICANTLY CLOSER TO REALITY
BECAUSE IT'S THE REAL COST THAT
WE REPORT ON CLAIMS THAT ARE
SUBMITTED TO THE STATE AND
AUDITED BY THE STATE PURSUANT TO
A FEDERALLY MANDATED COST
ALLOCATION PROCESS.
AND WE THINK YOU SHOULD DEFER TO
THE ACTUAL AND NOT THE PROXIES
WITH RESPECT TO THAT CONTINUOUS
CARE REFORM.
ON.
WE WOULD JUST UNDERSCORE SOME OF
THE ISSUES RAISED BY MISTER
JOHNSON.
FROM THE ALEJO WE BELIEVE THAT
EXCLUDING.
BACK LIKE CASES WHERE THERE IS
NOT IN EXISTING CHILD.
WE SHOULD BE ABOUT RE EXAMINED
WE HAVE FOR EXAMPLE RELATIVES
AWAITING APPROVAL WHO COULD BE
TAKING THEIR CAN.
CORPS IN THE BACKLOG AND SO WE
THINK IT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO
FUND THE ENTIRE BACK RIDE.
BACKLOG NOT JUST A SUBSET THAT
WAS FUNDED IN THE MAY REVISION.
I AM WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT.
WITH RESPECT TO THE LEVEL OF
CARE ASSESSMENT. AND CANS
THERE'S ACTUALLY SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE WORK FOR OUR WORKERS THAN
REFLECTED IN THAT IN THE MAY
REVISION THERE ARE SOME TIONS
FOR EXAMPLE.
WITH CANS WHICH ISN'T A MAJOR A
ASSESSMENT. THAT IT WILL REPLACE
NOT BE IN ADDITION TO
ASSESSMENTS THAT THE COUNTIES
ARE DOING CURRENTLY SO THE THE
MAY REVISE SAYS HEY WE THINK
THAT'S A WASH.
I'M WE DON'T BELIEVES THAT WE
PROVIDED AN ANALYSIS THAT
CROSSWALKS CURRENT REQUIREMENTS
TO THE NEW REQUIREMENTS THAT
SHOWS THE GAP FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WE UNDERSTAND THE
ADMINISTRATION. HASN'T DONE THAT
THAT SAME ANALYSIS BUT IT'S
WORKING ON IT BUT WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE IT. ARMED BECAUSE OUR
WORKERS AND OUR MEMBERS ARE
TELLING US THAT IT IS
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE WORK.
THAN CURRENT LAW AND FINALLY
WITH PAYMENT AT THE TIME OF
PLACEMENT NONE OF US HAVE HAD
SEEN THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
BUT I'D LIKE TO PUT A MARKER
AND.
WE ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE THAT
PROVIDER SHOULD GET STARK AND
PAID FROM THE MINUTE THEY GET A
CHILD THERE'S NO DISPUTE ABOUT
THAT. AB ONE TEN WAS A TERRIFIC
TEMPORARY COMPROMISE BUT IT
EXPIRES AND WHAT'S GOING IN ITS
PLACES AS WE UNDERSTAND IT
SOMETHING VERY DIFFERENT.
ARMED THERE WOULD BE NO STATE
GENERAL FUND CONTRIBUTION AND IT
WOULD BE A HUNDRED PERCENT
COUNTY RESPONSIBILITY. TO PAY
THROUGH EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE TNF
IT'S THE FUNDING SOURCE.
ARM AND THE COUNTIES WOULD HAVE
TO PICK UP TO THIRTY PERCENT NON
FEDERAL COST.
DAY STATE GENERAL FUND COST
THAT THEY WERE PUTTING IN UNDER
THE AB ONE TEN SOLUTION THE MAY
REVISE PULLS OUT.
AS WE UNDERSTAND IT THE MAY
REVISE ALSO SAYS THAT IF YOU'RE
A FAMILY AND YOU ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR E. A. ANY COULD BE
A SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF FAMILIES
WHERE YOU'VE EXPIRED.
I'M YOU'VE YOU'VE USED UP HERE
E. A YOU ARE NOT ELIGIBLE AS WE
UNDERSTAND IT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FOR
PAYMENT AT THE TIME OF
PLACEMENT.
WE DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
REASON TO EXCLUDE SOME SUBSET OF
THE POPULATION FROM THE
PRINCIPLE THAT FROM THE MOMENT
YOU TAKE A CHILD. YOU SHOULD BE
GETTING SUPPORTED FOR THAT CHILD
AND SELL WHEN THEN WHEN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE COMES OUT
WE WOULD CERTAINLY LIKE TO
ENGAGE. THE COMMITTEE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ON SOME OF THE
THOSE CONCERNS AS WELL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
STEPPED ARE.
MISTER CHAIR MY CAROL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY MEMBERS ALSO I'M HERE ON
TWO ON TWO ISSUES ONE IS WE'D
LIKE TO SAYS HERE ARE COMMENTS.
WITH THOSE TO MISTER MAC FROM
THE WALL FOR DIRECTORS ON THE
SINGLE ALLOCATION A WHILE WE'RE
PLEASED THAT THERE HAS BEEN A
DETERMINATION ON THE
ELIGIBILITY.
FORMULA WE STILL ARE CONCERNED
TOO ABOUT EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
AND LOOK FORWARD TO SOLVING THAT
GOING FORWARD AND HOPEFULLY.
PROTECTING THE COUNTIES BECAUSE
THAT IS REALLY WHAT THE PROGRAM
IS ABOUT IT'S ABOUT GETTING
THOSE EMPLOYMENT SERVICES TO OUR
CLIENTS SO THAT THEY CAN YOU
KNOW GET THROUGH THE PROCESS TO
GET OFF WELFARE AND. GET A JOB.
.
I ALSO WANT TO TALK BRIEFLY
ABOUT THE THREE HOUSING
PROPOSALS WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
ALL THREE OF THESE AUGMENTATIONS
WE HAVE BEEN BIG ADVOCATES OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS. FOR
INCREASING THE DAILY ALLOWANCE
FOR THE HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM WE THINK IS A VERY
IMPORTANT STEP ARM TO POINT THAT
WE WOULD JUST MAKE ONE IS. THAT
WHILE WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO SEE
THE STATE. ARM OF AND TAKING
SPECIFIC DIRECT ACTION AROUND
TRYING TO SOLVE SOME OF THE
HOMELESS PROBLEMS THAT ARE FIVE
FAMILIES HAVING THE COWARDS
PROGRAM. ON THAT WE WE DO WORRY
A LITTLE BIT THAT.
BUT THE FAMILIES FRANKLY DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THESE PROGRAMS AND
THEY'RE NOT REALLY CLEAR HOW TO
USE THEM I THINK ONE THING THE
COMMITTEE. MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
GOING FORWARD IS LOOKING AT HOW
THESE PROGRAMS DO FUNCTION
TOGETHER AND THE DEGREE TO WHICH
THEY MAY BE ABLE BE MORE
STREAMLINED AND EFFECTIVE.
WHEN WE SPOT WE TALK TO CLIENTS
ALL THE TIME AND WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THIS THEY REALLY DON'T
KNOW HOW YOU WORK HAVE WITH.
A JUST P. OR WITH FAMILY
MAINTENANCE THE FAMILY
STABILIZATION EXCUSE ME SO I
THINK GOING FORWARD WE NEED TO
BE THINKING ABOUT HOW WE DO
THAT.
AND THEN LASTLY I WOULD JUST SAY
.
THE CONTINUING NEED FOR HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE IS ALSO A REFLECTION
OF THE INADEQUACY OF OUR GRANT
LEVELS INVOLVE CAO WORKS AND THE
SSI PROGRAM WE ALSO ARE
SUPPORTING THE HOME SAFE
PROPOSAL WE THINK THAT'S.
WELL I A VERY IMPORTANT PROPOSAL
BUT WE ALSO THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT WE REYES SSI GRANTS TO
GET MORE INCOME INTO THE HANDS
OF THOSE FAMILIES TO SO I DON'T
WANT THAT THAT POINT TO BE LOST
IN THE TIME COMES. WE'RE HOPING
THE COMMITTEE CAN TAKE ACTION IN
THOSE AREAS ALSO THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR.
JUSTIN GARRETT I CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES A
LOT TO COMMENT ON SAW TEND TO
GROUP MY COMMENTS TOGETHER.
ON ITEMS NUMBER ONE IN FIVE
WITH THE COUNTY ADMINISTRATION
FUNDING WE GENUINELY APPRECIATE
THE PARTNERSHIP OF THE
COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENTS IN TERMS OF.
THE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS HAS
BEEN MADE WITH IDENTIFYING THE
ACCURATE COST SOME FOR COUNTIES
TO ADMINISTER THESE PROGRAMS AND
WE SHARE THE.
THAT THE COUPLE OF REMAINING
CONCERNS AT CW HAS IDENTIFIED IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO HOLD
COUNTIES HARMLESS TO THE LEVEL
FUNDING FOR THE SINKS IN THE
ALLOCATION. AND THEY'VE BEEN
ABLE TO ENSURE THAT ACTUAL COST
IT IS UTILIZED IN THE ICE AS
ADMIN METHODOLOGY.
FOR ITEMS TWO THREE AND FOUR WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF ALL OF THAT.
INVESTMENTS IN.
PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AND AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT. IMITATION
PRIORITIZE IN THIS ISSUE.
FOR ITEMS
SEVEN AND NINE RELATED TO A
COUNTY WORKLOAD WITH C. C. R.
IMPLEMENTATION WE APPRECIATE THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR BOTH OUR
F. A. N. ELSIE I'M WE CONTINUE
TO BELIEVE THAT THERE IS
ADDITIONAL. AYE COUNTY WORKLOAD
IS NOT YET ADEQUATELY AFFRONT
FUNDED INCLUDING ON THE KANSAS
HARASSMENT AND SO WOULD.
ALSO ADVOCATE FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THERE TO REFLECT ACTUAL
COSTS.
AND THEN FINALLY ON THE ISSUE OF
CCR PAYMENTS AT TIME OF
PLACEMENT. I'M WE DEFINITELY
SHARE THE SUPPORT FOR
IDENTIFYING A LONG TERM SOLUTION
ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE AND IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT THESE
FAMILIES ARE. ARE BEING PAID AT
THE TIME THAT THEY'RE CARING FOR
CHILDREN AND WE WOULD SHARE THE
CONCERNS THOUGH ABOUT THE
INCREASE COUNTY COSTS AND WHAT
WE UNDERSTAND TO BE IN THIS
PROPOSAL. AND WANTING TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND ENSURE THAT THAT'S
ADDRESSED A HOME FOR THE LONG
TERM SOLUTION ON THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
MISTER CHAIR DRAWING OF OR SOME
BEHALF URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA I'M REGARDING THE COW
WORKS HOUSING SUPPORT HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE WHICH ARE PART OF THE
GOVERNORS ARE HOMELESS PACKAGE.
WE HAVE A SUPPORTING CONCEPT ON
THE ENTIRE PACKAGE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS WITH THE CAL WORKS
ON HOUSING SIDE OF IT. IT'S
ACTUALLY IN THE ON THE HOUSING
SP TWO AND AND THE BRANCH A
GRANT THAT WE ASK QUESTIONS
ABOUT ON ALLOCATIONS WHICH
UNDERSTANDS CAN BE DEALT WITH IN
SUB FOUR SIGISMUND TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT FOR YOU. NUMBER ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE ADDITIONAL
INCREASES TO THE AYE JUSTICE
COUNTY AD MAN IN THE CCR BUT
OFFICE AIRLINER COMMENTS WITH
YOU ZUBIATE OTHERS REGARDING THE
FAIRNESS OF METHODOLOGY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOOD MORNING INTEREST FOR ITS UP
WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS I'M SPEAKING TO ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT THE CAREGIVER
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE AND WE ALSO
APPLAUD THE EFFORTS THAT WENT
INTO THE SHORT TERM SOLUTION
THROUGH AB ONE TAD ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE. THAT A LONG TERM
SOLUTION IS BEING WORKED OUT
THROUGH OF THE BUDGET PROCESS
BUT IT IS OUR FAMILIES THAT HAVE
BEEN BEARING THE BRUNT OF THE
REFORMS IN THE LEARNING CURVE.
AS THE STATE IN COUNTIES WORK
THROUGH HOW TO GET FAMILIES
APPROVED IN A TIMELY MANNER IT'S
OUR FAMILIES THAT HAVE BEEN
HOLDING THE BAG AND IT APPEARS
THAT WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED
THROUGH MAY REVISE. IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO PUT MANY OF THESE
FAMILIES IN THE LURCH BECAUSE
THERE ARE FOUR THINGS THAT NEED
TO BE FIXED THROUGH THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE LONG TERM
SOLUTION.
ACTUALLY WORKS FOR ALL OF THE
FAMILIES THAT TAKEN A CHILD
PRIOR TO BEING APPROVED THE
FIRST IS THAT THERE HAS TO BE
FUNDING FROM THE MOMENT A
PLACEMENT. ALL THE WAY THROUGH
TO APPROVAL AND IT APPEARS THAT
THE SHORT TERM OR THE LONG TERM
SOLUTION IS LIMITING FUNDING TO
SIX MONTHS IN THIS FISCAL YEAR
AND NINETY DAYS IN SUBSEQUENT
FISCAL YEARS. AND IT IS NOT
POSSIBLE ALWAYS TO GET FAMILIES
THROUGH THE APPROVAL PROCESS
WITHIN SIX MONTHS WE KNOW THERE
ARE MANY MANY FAMILIES RIGHT
NOW.
THAT HAVE BEEN PENDING FOR MUCH
LONGER THAN SIX MONTHS SO THE
SOLUTION HAS TO ACCOUNT FOR
THOSE FAMILIES WHO THE ENTIRE
PERIOD OF TIME. IT ALSO NEEDS TO
BE AT THE MOMENT A PLACEMENT
WHICH EVERYONE KEEPS SAYING BUT
WHAT ACTUALLY HAS BEEN IN THE
SHORT TERM SOLUTION AND PROPOSED
IN THE LONG TERM SOLUTION. IS
THAT THE FUNDING IS TIED TO THE
APPLICATION OF THE RK
APPLICATION SOMETIMES FAMILIES
ARE PROVIDED THOSE APPLICATIONS
RIGHT AWAY EVEN WHEN THEY ASK
FOR THEM ARE OFTEN NOT PROVIDED
THE APPLICATIONS ARE FAMILIES
DON'T HAVE CONTROL. OVER WHETHER
OR NOT THE APPLICATIONS ARE
SUBMITTED AND SO SAYING THAT THE
FUNDING DOESN'T START UNTIL THE
COUNTIES GET THOSE APPLICATIONS
AND AGAIN JUST LEAVES THE
FAMILIES THE ONES. THAT ARE
BEARING THE PRICE OF THESE
REFORMS.
AND THERE HAS TO BE CONTINUITY
BETWEEN THE SHORT TERM SOLUTION
AND THE LONG TERM SOLUTIONS
OFFER MOVING AWAY FROM THE ART
PROGRAM FOR FUNDING FAMILIES AND
PUTTING ALL OF THE FAMILIES INTO
THE E. A PROGRAM WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT FAMILIES AREN'T.
LEFT IN THE LURCH AS A
TRANSITION FROM ARC OVER TO
A AND IN THE FINALLY AS A
MISTER MECCA SPOKE TO E. A ISN'T
GOING TO COVER ALL OF OUR
FAMILIES. NOT EVERY FAMILY IS
GOING TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR E. A
ARE UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE
CHILDREN WITH INCOME OF THEIR
OWN AREN'T ELIGIBLE FOR
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE. AND KIDS
THAT HAVE BEEN IN CARE FOR MORE
THAN TWELVE MONTHS ARE OFTEN NOT
GOING TO BE ELIGIBLE AND THOSE
CHILDREN ALSO NEED TO BE FUNDED
AT THE MOMENT A PLACEMENT THANK
YOU.
A HUMAN.
SUZANNE ANATHEMA CHILDREN NOW
ALSO HERE WITH CONCERNS ON WHAT
WE'RE HEARING ABOUT FUNDING AT
THE TIMETHE PLACEMENT VERY
CHALLENGING TO SPEAK WE HAVEN'T
YET SEEN TBL WE HOPE THAT'S
COMING OUT SOON.
BUT IN THE ABSENCE OF THAT
AGAIN SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE HEARD AND DON'T REALLY JIVE
WITH WHAT WE ALL AGREED TO ILL
AND THIS SPRING AND WHAT THIS
LEGISLATURE VERY THOUGHTFULLY
HELPED US COLLABORATING GET TO A
GOOD PLACE ON. WRESTLING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE ONCE AGAIN STEP
THEN AND HELPED NEGOTIATE A
BETTER AGREEMENT THIS CAN'T BE A
FIGHT BETWEEN STAYING COUNTIES
OVER WHO PAYS WE NEED TO
REMEMBER IT'S ABOUT FAMILIES.
MAKING SURE THAT THEY GET
FUNDING AT THE TIME THE
PLACEMENT AND THAT THAT
CONTINUES UNTIL THE APPLICATIONS
ARE DONE.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
KELLY BROOKS I'M HERE TO COMMENT
ON SEVERAL ITEMS ON ON ISSUE
NUMBER ONE THE COLORED SINGLE
OCCASION I'M HERE IN SUPPORT.
ON BEHALF OF THE COLUSA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN THE
THING CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE'D ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS THE
FUNDING SHORTFALLS.
IN THE EMPLOYMENT.
SERVICE AS PART OF THAT SINGLE
ALLOCATION ON ON ISSUE NUMBER
TWO THAT CAL ARTS HOUSING
SUPPORT PROGRAM I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARA AND
ENTER A COUNTY BOARDS. I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THE OF MAY REVISE ON
I WANNA PUT A PLUG IN ON BEHALF
OF VENTURA WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE TRAILER BILL TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE IS FLEXIBLE
ENOUGH.
TO ALLOW CAO WORKS FAMILIES WHO
WERE DISPLACED DUE TO THE
WILDFIRES TO BE ABLE TO QUALIFY
FOR THE I'M HOUSING SUPPORTS.
VENTURE AND SANTA CLARA.
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ALSO
SUPPORT THAT.
INCREASED ABOUT HOW WORKS
HOMELESS ASSISTANT PROGRAM
PAYMENT RATES.
I'M ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
RIVERSIDE SANTA CLARA SANTA CRUZ
AND THE VENTURA COUNTY.
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ON THE EPS
HOME SAFE PROPOSAL.
WERE ALL IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL AND AND WOULD ENCOURAGE
THE ADMINISTRATION TO LOOK AT
THAT PROPOSED TRICKS TO THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE PROPOSED
BY THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. TO MAKE ADDITIONAL
GROUPS OF SENIORS.
PRETTY LOW THOSE LIVING IN
SHORT TERM LIVING ARRANGEMENTS
ELIGIBLE.
AND THEN FINALLY.
ON BEHALF OF THE VENTURA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WANT TO
COMMENT ON THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
REFORM FUNDING WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WERE ACTUALLY FUNDING
THAT COUNTY WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH.
IMPLEMENTING THE NEW CHANGES
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
ROSANNA CURVATURE HERE WE HAVE
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AYE WE WANT TO THANK
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THE MAY
REVISE AND INCLUDING THE MONEY
FOR THE ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES.
PROGRAM AND I ALSO JUST WANT TO
ECHO THE CONCERNS RAISED BY CW
DE A ON.
HOW WORK SINGLE ALLOCATION ISSUE
AND I HOPE THOSE WILL BE ABLE TO
FOR YOU RESOLVED THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM?
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ENTER SHANE
FROM CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS ALSO A CALIFORNIA'S
PRESSES SIGH. I WANT ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMITMENTS
TO MECCA AND MISTER HAROLD ON
THE SINK I ALLOCATION I WOULD
JUST POINT OUT THAT EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW THE
CAL WORKS EMPLOYMENT SERVICES.
ON THE STEP SIDE WE CERTAINLY
DON'T SEEM REDUCTION AND AND
EMPLOYMENT ON TRAIN STAFF AT THE
COUNTIES OVER THE LOSS OF THE
ABOUT WAIVER. IN AT LEAST THREE
COUNTIES AND CERTAINLY THAT THE
DISCUSSIONS GOING ON THE HOUSE
FARM BILL THE STUFFING MORE PORN
THAN EVER. ASSERTIONS ARE CROSS
TRAIN FOR SNAP HOUSEHOLDS.
BONTA AS WELL AS IN SUPPORT OF
THE ITEM TWO THREE AND FOUR ON
HOUSING ON AND IS AND ALSO ON
FOURTEEN ON DISASTERS WE
CERTAINLY KNOW THAT THE FOOD
BANKS I EXPERIENCE THE STRONG
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COUNTY IN
STATES IN IMPLEMENTING THOSE
PROGRAMS AND APPRECIATE. THE
DISASTER ASSISTANCE
FINALLY FOR CALIFORNIA TRUSTS
AYE AYES HAVE TO CLOSE BY SAYING
HOW DISAPPOINTING IT IS TO SEE.
THE SAVINGS FROM THE REDUCE
CASELOAD OF THIRTY FOUR AND
CHANGE IT ESTIMATED THAT HALF
WAY TO A COLA FOR FOR THE YEAR
AND TO SEE AFTER YEARS OF
ADVOCACY.
THE LACK OF INVEST IN THE
PROGRAM IS ACTUALLY FRUSTRATING
AND AS AS MISTER HAROLD SAID WE
HOPE IS HE'S NOT.
THANK YOU SIR.
REVENUE MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ON
MARTHA GARAGE REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND FIRST I WANT TO
START OFF WITH ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN.
INDIAN MERCHANT TELECARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL.
FOR THE FUNDING FOR THAT
PROGRAM SOMETHING LOS ANGELES
COUNTY'S ADVOCATED FOR STRONGLY
AND.
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT FOR THAT
PROGRAM. AND IN ADDITION WITH
THE ADULT VICTIMS SERVICES HOME
SAFE PROGRAM AND WE ARE ALSO
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF AND THANKFUL
FOR THE FUNDING.
BUT ALSO.
INTERESTED IN ADDING IN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THE
ADDITIONAL POPULATIONS.
FOR THE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES.
COUNTY ADMIN WE.
ARE IN.
SUPPORT OF THE CWD
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE AYE AGES
S. ADMIN AND.
FOR THE CAL WORK SINGLE
LOCATION WE WOULD APPRECIATE ON
THE FUNDING AS RECOMMENDED BY CW
DE A.
SO WE'D LIKE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THAT.
A REGARDING THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORM THE NUMBER OF ISSUES
THAT WERE RAISED OF THE SAME
CONCERNS THAT.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS RAISING
THAT IS A PROBLEM AREA OF OF
NEED AND THE MANY CHANGES FOR
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE MAGNITUDE
OF. THAT LOS ANGELES COUNTY HAS
BEEN PLACED AND THE LACK OF
FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT THIS
ADMINISTRATIVELY AND IT SHOWS
WITH THE NUMBERS. ON THE
HARDSHIP THAT'S BEEN PLACED ON
THE COUNTY TO BE ABE TO DO THIS
WE UTILIZE FIRST FUNDING TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE PAYMENT AT THE
TIME OF PLACEMENT. WE SAW THE
URGENCY IN THE NEED FOR A
FAMILIES TO HAVE THAT AND SO WE
ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE AND THANKFUL
FOR AB ONE TEN WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU. ON TO
SEE HOW WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
THAT PAYMENT AND NOT. A PLACE
THAT BURDEN ON COUNTIES THANK
YOU PICKING UP.
HI CELINA PRIOR WITH ASCII YOU
WE WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH MR MECCA'S
COMMENTS IN REGARD TO SINGLE
ALLOCATION AND CC ORANGES ADDS
THAT. ARE MEMBERS OF OUR
EMPLOYMENT SERVICE WORKERS AND
SOCIAL WORKERS WE ARE COMMITTED
TO THE WORK THAT WE DO BUT WE
CANNOT DO THE WORK WITHOUT
ADEQUATE RESOURCES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE THREE.
SEEING NONE ALL BRING IT UP TO
THE COMMITTEE AND I HAVE A FEW
COMMENTS IF I MAY. AND I WANTED
TO START WITH SOME THANK YOUS I.
.
SIGNIFICANTLY APPRECIATE WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION DID.
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS A CHRONIC
PROBLEM FOR OUR STATE AND
HOMELESSNESS.
BOTH OF THE PROGRAMS AND CAL
WORKS ARE MUCH NEEDED AND ARE
ANXIOUS.
ADDITIONALLY THE HOME SAFE
PROGRAM THAT WAS FUNDED IS ONE
THAT.
SPOKE TO MANY OF US ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND ARE QUITE PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION
AND PURSUING.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
FIXED PURSES VARIABLE COST
DISCUSSIONS THAT WERE ADDRESSING
THAT THE COW WORK SINGLE
ALLOCATION I THINK.
WHILE IT'S NOT IDEAL YET IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND WANT TO APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
DONE. TO HELP WITH THAT. IN
ADDITION I WANTED TO THANK YOU
FOR THE PAYMENT AT THE TIME OF
PLACEMENT.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US AS
A STATE TO PUT OUR VALUES FIRST.
ON THIS ISSUE AND WANT TO
CONTINUE TO SEE AS WE LOOK
TOWARDS A LONG TERM SOLUTION.
HOW WE AS A STATE ARE MORE
MODELING AFTER AB ONE TEN?
THAT WE MAKE SURE WE HAVE OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES AS A STATE AND
PLACE OUR VALUES FIRST AND
FOREMOST.
WANTED TO COMMENT IF I COULD ON
A FEW OF THE OTHER ISSUES THAT
WERE TOUCHED ON.
ONE THAT IS THAT CURRENTLY
SPEAKING TO ME AND THIS ONE I'M
GOING TO WANT TO.
SPEAK TO THE.
DEPARTMENTS ABOUT IS REGARDING
CANS FOR CC ARE.
I HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
ABOUT ITS USE AS A TOOL.
AND WOULD LIKE TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND IF WE AS A STATE ARE
EXPOSING OURSELVES TO
SIGNIFICANT COST. WHY WE HAVE
SELECTED THAT TOOL AND IS THAT
THE RIGHT ONE?
WHAT WE ARE GOING TO WANT TO
LOOK AT IS WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S A PHASE AND POSSIBILITY?
COULD WE AS A STATE POTENTIALLY.
.
THAT EMPLOYMENT AND LOOK AT
WHETHER THIS IS THE APPROPRIATE
TO ON HOW WE WOULD DO THAT I
WILL LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOUR TEAM.
WE HAVE SOME POTENTIAL IDEAS
WE'D LIKE TO PROPOSE.
BUT HAVE SOME CONCERNS THAT IT
DOES AND WILL REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS.
AND THAT THOSE ACTUAL COSTS WILL
BE BORNE BY THE STATE AND WANTS
TO ENSURE THAT.
WE HAVE SELECTED THE RIGHT TOOL
FOR THE RIGHT PLACES
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
ON THAT.
I'M REGARDING THE.
ISSUE SEVEN OF THE RFA BACKLOG.
.
I WOULD ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT.
WHY WE AREN'T?
TRYING TO FIX THE ENTIRE
BACKLOG.
SO THAT WE CAN PLACE AS MANY
FAMILIES AS POSSIBLE AND.
WOOD LOOKS TO ASK THE
DEPARTMENT AGAIN WHY BIT FOCUSED
ON A SECTION OF IT RATHER THAN
THE ENTIRETY OF THE BACKLOG AND
WHAT THE REASONING WAS BEHIND
THAT.
SO THAT WILL BE A QUESTION.
AND THEN FINALLY REGARDING THE
LEVEL OF CARE ASSESSMENT ISSUE
NINE. WANTED TO. GET AN
UNDERSTANDING IT SEEMS THAT THE
COUNTIES AND CWD A ARE. BOTH
SAYING THAT THE.
RFA BACKLOG IN THE LEVEL OF CARE
HAVE NOT.
THAT ARE THERE NOT ENOUGH.
AND I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE
METHODOLOGY BEHIND WHY THOSE
NUMBERS WERE SELECTED AND
WHETHER IT.
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSES.
THE NEEDS THAT WE HAVE.
BUT I HAVE.
PITCHER BANKER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AGAIN.
LET LET ME START FIRST WITH THE
A RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
BACKLOG ON THEM.
WE TAILOR DE WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THE EFFORT HERE IS ON GOING
THERE IS A BASELINE OF FINDING
FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
PROCESS.
NOT ALL COUNTIES HAVE FULLY
EXPANDED DOT AND THEY CONTINUE
TO TO WORK ON THAT. DID THIS
INVESTMENT IS TARGETED PIT
SPECIFICALLY TO THE BACKLOG AND
SPECIFICALLY TO THE BACKLOG
WHERE PLACEMENTS ACTUALLY EXIST
NOW.
BECAUSE WE THINK THAT'S THE
FIRST PRIORITY FOR WHERE
ATTENTION SHOULD BE FOCUSED.
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT WE DON'T
STILL NEED RESOURCE FAMILIES TO
BE APPROVED SO THAT THEY'RE
AVAILABLE FOR FOR CHILDREN.
THAT NEED THAT PLACEMENT.
BUT WHEN THERE ISN'T AN ACTIVE
CHILD THERE OR IT'S NOT
UNNECESSARILY A PLACE THAT'S
ACTIVELY UNDER CONSIDERATION WE
THINK THAT'S A LOWER PRIORITY
THAN WHERE CHILDREN ARE TODAY
AND THAT'S THE. THE RATIONALE
GENERALLY SPEAKING FOR FOR WHY
WE TARGETED THAT PIECE OF THE
BACKLOG SO IT SOUNDS AS IF
YOU'RE SAYING THERE'S LOW
HANGING FRUIT THAT. WE SHOULD BE
ADDRESSING FIRST AND FOREMOST.
I GUESS THE QUESTION I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND IS.
DOES THE REMAINDER OF THE
BACKLOG INHIBIT PLACEMENT OF
FOSTER KIDS NOW.
AND WHAT IT. BENEFIT US IS A
STATE TO TAKE CARE OF THE ENTIRE
BACKLOG.
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THAT I
THINK EIGHT IN ADDITION TO THIS
INVESTMENT AS I MENTIONED
THERE'S A BASELINE LEVEL OF
FUNDING FOR RESOURCE FAMILIES.
AND.
APPROVAL PROCESS SEES AND I
THINK THE COMBINATION OF THE
TWO.
DIMINISHING THIS PART OF THE
BACKLOG AYE I WOULD SAYIS THAT
THE HIGH HANGING MOST OF THE
HIGH PRIORITY.
FRUIT IF YOU WILL.
AND THAT THE BASELINE LEVEL OF
FUNDING WE BELIEVE IS IS
ADEQUATE IT'S CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT WE'VE PROPOSED A
HISTORICALLY AND OTHERS HAVE
FOUND ACCEPTABLE WE THINK THE
REST OF THE BACKLOG WILL RESOLVE
ITSELF OVER TIME. AS EVERYBODY
TOGETHER GETS BETTER AT AT THE
FAMILY APPROVAL PROCESS SO I
I'M.
TELLING YOU THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION FEELS
COMFORTABLE.
THAT THE ENTIRE BACKLOG WILL
OVER TIME.
.
BE RESOLVED BY BY THE LEVEL OF
INVESTMENT.
THAT WE BELIEVE HAS AS A
ACCURATELY.
IN THE BUDGET AND I JUST WANT TO
PUT A PIN INTO THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE LEVEL OF CARE
ASSESSMENT AS. I DO NOT
UNDERSTAND THIS IS AN ONGOING.
ASSESSMENT WILL NEED
ADJUSTMENTS THROUGH TIME BUTTON.
JUST.
ONCE TED ECHO AND MAKE SURE
WE'RE BEING RECEPTIVE TO WHAT
WE'RE HEARING ON THE GROUND AS
WELL.
FINALLY REGARDING ISSUE EIGHT.
.
YOU KNOW I'M. EAGERLY
ANTICIPATING THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AS WELL TO REALLY GET
AN UNDERSTANDING.
.
THAT BUT WHO.
I HAVE CONCERNS IF WERE NOT
CREATING THE CONTINUITY OF THE
PROGRAM.
AND SO AGAIN JUST WANT US TO AS
MUCH AS WE CAN TO FOLLOW THE.
INTENT OF WHAT A. B. ONE TEN
WAS TRYING TO DO AND SEE THAT
THIS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
REFLECTS MORE OF THAT THAN.
WHAT WE'RE HEARING HERE TODAY
SO?
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
THREE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
FOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GOOD MORNING DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
BRAIN DOOR HEAT.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES AT
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT.
THE PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF YOU IS
A TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT IS PART
OF THE NAY REVISION. IT PROPOSES
TO INCREASE OUR FEDERAL
AUTHORITY BY THIRTY THREE POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR BOTH THE LOW INCOME HOME
ENERGY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AND
THE COMMUNITY SERVICES BLOCK
GRANT. TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
ADEQUATE EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
FOR THOSE TWO FEDERAL GRANTS AND
THAT FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO LIVE.
JENNY BELLA LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL THEY
SORT OF ALERTED US THAT THIS MAY
BE HAPPENING THROUGHOUT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE PROCESS WE'RE
LOOKING FOR.
THANK YOU.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE FOR.
SEEING NONE WANT TO THANK THE
DEPARTMENT WILL HOLD ISSUE FOR
OPEN IN THE BOND ISSUE FIVE
.
GOOD MORNING MARC BACK WAY TO
PERMIT CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES.
IN YOUR AGENDA THE.
TELLS FOR SERVICES DEPARTMENT
IS REQUESTING A MINOR TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT AND THAT'S TO
REBALANCE ARE FEDERAL TRUST FUND
WITH OURSELVES FOR RECOVERY
FUND.
UNDER FEDERAL REGULATIONS HER
CARDIFF SPEND DOWN OUR FEDERAL
FUNDS FEDERAL COLLECTION FUNDS
FIRST BEFORE TRYING TO ADD
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL TRUST FUND.
SINCE HER EXPERIENCE AN INCREASE
AND FEDERAL.
COLLECTION FUNDS REQUESTING
ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY OF SEVEN
HAD BEEN THREE THOUSAND INTO
ITEM FIFTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE ONE
ON ONE A ONE EIGHT ZERO ZERO
FOUR. MAY DECREASE.
CORRESPONDING WAVE OF THE SAME
AMOUNT. AND ITEM FIFTY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE ONE A ONE AWAY
NINETY.
WE I AM ALSO HAVE A BRIEF UPDATE
ON OUR COLLECTIONS.
NOT FOR TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN. WE ARE ADVISING OUR
COLLECTIONS ASTHMA DOWNWARD BY
TWO PERCENT.
FOR.
.
PATH FOR THE YEAR. NOW THIS IS
STILL A ONE POINT ONE PERCENT
ABOUT A TWENTY SIX AND MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE.
FROM THE.
TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN ACTUAL
COLLECTIONS LEVEL. WERE ALSO
PROPOSING TO REVISE OUR ESTIMATE
DOWNWARDS BY ABOUT EIGHT TEN
PERCENT EIGHT TENTHS OF ONE
PERCENT.
I'M FROM THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
LEVEL BUT THIS IS STILL A NET
INCREASE OVER THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN REVISED
LEVEL.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ELLIOTT.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THE ISSUE
FIVE.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU AGAIN AND
THAT WILL INCLUDE TODAY'S HERE
RIGHT